2,000 Marines and sailors are being
deployed to Israeli Waters and they're
being prepared for a potential
deployment into the country at the same
time Janet Yellen reassures all of us
yes the United States can afford to Wars
and don't worry when Joe Biden was asked
on 60 Minutes he also confirmed come on
we're the most powerful nation in the
history not not just the world the
history of the world we can handle it
they're gearing up for for a major
escalation of War and the argument is
that by sending the troops in it will
prevent War but uh let's let's be real
if the US actually deploys Ground Forces
into Israel wow talk about a dramatic
escalation at a time we've already been
seeing attacks from Syria and Israel
Lebanon and Israel back and forth
there's now threats from Lindsey Graham
Lindsey Graham says that we should bomb
Iran with or without
evidence I hope you guys are ready for
the war that they are about to start
pains me to say we'll talk about that
plus a whole bunch of other uh uh man
it's just it's it's it's wild it's wild
today's a crazy day we had this horrible
incident in I think it was Brussels
right where uh a man attacked I just
it's a tragedy he killed people I
believe they died right just want to
make sure I'm really really clear on
this one two and then three yeah and it
was revenge over another kid who was
Muslim who was attacked and and and it's
just getting crazy out there so we're
going to talk about all that but before
we do there's one brand that doesn't
mind sponsoring content that is uh War
related and that's us Casper coffee we
sponsor ourselves for this reason look I
get it man if you're selling toothpaste
do you really want your toothpaste
commercial to be right next to someone
being like several people died in war
today probably not but we sponsor
ourselves that means if you like the
work that we do if you think this
coverage is important you go to
casper.com and you buy a bag of Casper
coffee we got pumpkin spice Mr B's
pumpkin spice experience right now cuz
it is pumpkin spice season but of course
we got a whole bunch of of other Blends
appalache nights is my favorite rise
with Roberto Jr close second buy our
coffee support the work we do and it's
uh it's pretty good but also more
importantly support our work directly by
going to
timcast.net got pre-shows they got after
shows and as a member you can submit
questions and call into our members only
uncensored show Monday through Thursday
at 10 p.m. and actually talk to us and
our guest so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about this and a whole lot more we
got Josie the redheaded libertarian hi
thanks for having me yeah who are you
what are you doing I am Josie I'm the
redheaded libertarian I do outside media
work for uh
timcast.net having on VC ramaswami so
you can go to my page TRL official and
uh find my link there and uh watch the
show cool we got Hannah Clair brimo
hanging out hey I'm Hannah Clair brimo
I'm a writer for
timcast.net and I just think that Jan
Janet yen is pulling a girl math moment
when she says we can afford two Wars I
think that's girl math this is this
thing where like justify spending money
in a way that doesn't actually make
sense this is what is doing she's giving
this very female episode of timcast a
horrible way to start anyways Libby's
here of course hey Hannah CLA hey Josie
hey Tim glad to be here I'm Libby Emmons
I am the editorinchief at the
post-millennial and human events Ian uh
ascended can't do anything about he just
goney go think about the 51st well he
was he was meditating and then I just
saw him lift up into the sky and then I
was like well I'll call Libby and see if
she's around yeah this check here I am
he's just gone welcome Lou thanks no
he'll be back next week he's uh uh doing
a bunch of shows and stuff down in Miami
so that's right thanks for hanging out
Libby we got search pressing the buttons
yeah I here uh babooka let's uh win in
the semis guys anyways start the show
here's a story from
CNN US Marine rapid response force
moving toward Israel as Pentagon
strengthens military posture in region I
love how they're very careful with their
headline let's be real this is a
deployment but here's how they phrase it
as as after you read the headline moving
towards what does that mean a US Marine
rapid response force is headed to the
waters off the coast of Israel and the
Pentagon is preparing American troops
for a potential deployment to the
country escalating the US's show of
force in the region as it works to
prevent the conflict between Israel and
Hamas from widening any further a
defense official familiar with the
planning said the rapid response Force
consisting of 2,000 Marines and sailors
is being sent it will join a growing
number of us warships and forces
converging on Israel as the US seeks to
send a message of deterrence to Iran and
the Lebanese militant group Hezbollah on
Sunday evening US Secretary of Defense
Lloyd Austin ordered that roughly 2,000
troops prepare for a potential
deployment to Israel to help with the
tasks like medical and lo logistical
support multiple defense official says
uh in other words the US is entering the
war yes no no we're just entering near
the war war we're just moving towards
the War I hate that phrasing I think
that's so lame well we did that in Kev
too because we have special forces in
Kei MH hanging out and we haven't
declared a war since World War II so
this is just more run-of-the-mill well
we don't have a house speaker so we
can't really declare much of anything at
all oh golly what time maybe that's good
then though maybe that's good Silver
Lining to that situation well the only
issue though is that of course Biden can
do pretty much whatever he wants which
is what we're seeing play out right now
kind of makes it's not really Biden I
mean Biden's staffers can do whatever
they want it kind of makes you wonder
about the timing because they kept not
working on Sunday or not working
Saturday not working Sunday not working
Monday and it's like they were putting
off this vote and now all of a sudden
there are Marines headed to Israel
without without Congress even in session
like I mean that's amazing yeah that is
pretty upsetting actually so so here's
what
happens I'm not saying this is
definitive absolute absolutely going to
happen but how do you as the president
get the us into a war without a
declaration from Congress well for the
most part they've just done it they just
send the troops they send us Marines and
warships into the Mediterranean they
send it into Israeli Waters and then
what happens when Hezbollah
attacks now you don't need a declaration
now it's we're being fired upon we have
to react our ships that we put there
strategically are now under attack
that's right it's crazy how that happens
what's Wild is remember when they said
Trump was going to start World War II
and how Biden came in and said now the
adults are in charge and then he
proceeded to destroy everything how long
until they're like well actually this is
all Trump's fault in the first place
anyways if Trump had never been
president I I feel like they'll always
say it but there'll be some specific
state statement from Biden that's like
ultimately this is all Trump's fault
even though I have been in office for
basically would not have escalated if
not for Donald Trump doing nothing I
don't know he'll come up with well Hamas
has been planning this attack for 2
years which is basically when Biden took
office they started planning this attack
exactly because when Trump was in office
he was strong enough he had an
interesting quote today he was speaking
in Iowa and he said he said that his
personality had kept us out of War
that's not wrong it's entirely right I
mean as I've said about Trump in the
past like the thing about Trump is he
appears to be an absolute crazy man and
you stay away from a crazy man a crazy
man will do crazy things so you kind of
back off you let him do his whole crazy
thing and that's a big part of what made
him so effective is that he was
unpredictable you never quite knew what
kind of thing he was going to do right
down to the Abraham Accords which were
actually pretty genius because they were
these bilateral agreement well that's
kind of the opposite I mean it's not
just that Trump threatened to Nuke
Moscow and uh uh and what what else what
else did he threatened Moscow and China
a littleit well China which which city
was it he said he was going to there was
two cities nuke the out of one
right he said no no no he he has that
famous quote where he said he would nuke
Moscow and then and Beijing yes yeah I'm
like it's it wasn't Shin Jang I mean
that's not Beijing right of course he
also had that threat that he did on
Twitter at the time about like do not
come at me Iran or something like you
will you will experience like a hell
you've never seen before but I think I
think for for Russia for instance they
have no reason to invade Ukraine When
Donald Trump is saying we're getting our
troops out of the Middle East this is
ridiculous you know what are we here for
oil and so that was a big part of the
conflict is the US basically trying to
force Russia's energy business into the
gutter and instead of competing on the
open market When Donald Trump starts
saying look we're not going to go to war
for this we're going to do energy our
way we're going to start drilling for
oil in the United States we've got
Alaska we could do all these things and
he did and gas prices go down now gas
prices went down dramatically every
people failed to mention this because of
Co because demand was in the gutter and
they had to give oil away it was crazy
but it's still was relatively cheap even
before this and so Russia's incentive
for war is minimal then you get the
Abraham Accords why because there's an
economic incentive now from the West I
mean this is brilliant
stuff what happens then is the the uh
the left is arguing that this conflict
between Hamas in Israel is Trump's fault
because of the Abraham Accords because
it marginalizing sidelined Hamas and
their only action was going to be
military conflict and I'll push back on
that and say if Donald Trump's policies
were still in place then the incentives
of Saudi Arabia and qar and the Emirates
Etc would be to align with Israel
because their deal is being jeopardized
by the actions of Hamas instead you get
Joe Biden and his administration that
doesn't care for these negotiations and
wants War well and that's exactly what
happened right you have Saudi Arabia
which was doing negotiations with Israel
they were cooling some tensions and now
that has to totally been scuttled as a
result of the Hamas attack um so I think
that's been that's been pretty effective
and if if what the Biden Administration
wants is permanent War which it does
seem like that is what they're
interested in um then it would make
sense that they would continue to help
escalate the situation I mean it always
I can't help but think of months before
Russia invaded Ukraine there was that
phone call between Putin and Biden were
pu said if you promise that they are not
going to join NATO we will not invade
Ukraine and I can only imagine you know
I don't know what Biden said in response
other than no we're not going to do that
but I can only imagine these two
personalities were not going to have a
productive conversation the relationship
between the US and Russia was the
strongest at least in most recent years
when Donald Trump was in office because
Putin respects him more than he respects
Biden yeah you also had kamla Harris
coming out saying that Ukraine was going
to join NATO at some point you have all
of these overtures from the EU to bring
Ukraine in and Ukraine doesn't Ukraine
like mean Border Lands essentially so if
you take Ukraine away then suddenly
Europe is and NATO and the EU are right
on the doorstep of Russia and that's a
threat to them like there needs to be
right we act they want this barrier
right we act like they're uh concerned
that the NATO border is being expanded
directly next to them is is sort of
absurd when it's not I mean you can
disagree with all kinds of other things
but this idea that this was one of the
contingencies for not invading and that
Biden just said no oh I'm against this
and whatever you know obviously we we're
setting the Biden Administration did not
take steps that were necessary to
deescalate a situation in fact now that
we see that apparently Yellen is like
yes we can afford another war of course
they want another War because who among
them makes money probably all of them we
also have this tweet from someone I
don't know who but it's under the Biden
Twitter account X account saying an
attack on one group of us is an attack
on all of us in America hate will not
Prevail Venom and violence against any
one Community cannot stand and will not
be the story of our time who's even who
is he who is Karen Jean Pierre even
talking about there I think talking
about and talking to I think it should
be illegal for uh anyone but the
president to post from the president's
account I completely agree uh but it
should say like pus little staffers or
something account it should that should
be the account pus staff but this
account should only be the president due
to the fact that it's public record as
statements of the president right I feel
like this is a statement from the Biden
administration at large it's not the
Biden himself that's true of the White
House I mean the White House puts out
statements all the time that are
attributed to the Biden to Joe Biden
even though he is unlikely to have
written them yeah in theory he would
have read them and signed off on them
though
I think he does that to all the
briefings no I don't even think this man
reads any of the briefings but that's
because I don't trust him it should be a
legal requirement that a president sign
off on any statement attributed to the
president for the sake of public records
yeah he should sign off off on it before
he takes the documents and puts them in
his garage yeah that means if they want
to write on his for Twitter for X then
they have to get approval from him and
he has to sign it he has to sign off on
it yeah I think that makes a lot of
sense he has to have his own tweets to
have a I'm Joe Biden and I approve this
message why but this is this is
basically more war postering right for
sure the attack on one group is an
attack on all of us here we go and
they're going to say you're either with
us or the terrorists Etc yeah textbook
yeah but I don't think that Joe Biden is
in a position to argue with with his own
staff right I don't think I I personally
think Jo Biden would be happy to go to
war but on top of that he's not checking
his own Twitter he's probably not
reading the briefings I mean he is not
in a position to challenge whichever
staff are saying no Mr P president this
is a good line um I mean even last week
when we had him say I never thought i'
I'd be able to confirm he had that weird
statement about the the photos of the
children and then it was like the white
white house then fact checked him this
didn't happen which is not a great look
I mean Biden wants to go to war his
administration his Stafford underne have
their own reasons for wanting to go to
war and either way it's going to hurt
the American people well sure that's
what war does I mean unless we like uh
ramp up our Munitions and actually start
spending a lot of money and creating a
better War Machine and then getting rich
off that like we've done countless times
before that's also effective I'm kind of
noticing a pattern with how uh the way
we withdrew from Afghanistan and then
went to Ukraine kind of noticing like
they kind of losing steam with the
Ukraine thing but now Israel's like the
next big thing so they're like yeah you
know it's kind of going to take a back a
back uh a back seat to Sauron take look
at this must be so mad right now this
just popped up right now on the website
for the article we had us secretary of
state blinkin speaks after meeting with
Israeli War cabinet for more than seven
hours watch on CNN well we're not
watching CNN but that's the breaking
news right now he's speaking I wonder
what he'll be saying we'll pick up those
updates uh in a minute after they come
out you know know outside of the video
but uh I think we're dangerously close
to World War II and I think it's a uh I
mean World War I what does it even mean
uh I think at some point within the next
12 months there's going to be a dramatic
and massive
mobilization I mean and and it's not
even a bold prediction to say something
like that we're looking at 2,000 Marines
and sailors deploying to Israeli Waters
and there's already warships there so
like if this
escalates WOW who could have seen that
coming Iran is to Russia as Israel is to
the United States in my opinion um so I
feel like if if like what Lindsey Graham
really wants to do this like he is just
so ready but if they if we do something
to Iran that's going to get Russia
involved it would be my fear and that
that would just be the escalation and
then if you have China and Taiwan
happening kind of over there and a
separate separate thing going on like
it's we're we're primed for escalations
everywhere everywhere I I wonder about
how this could play out I mean the US is
still the most powerful military force I
mean how many aircraft carriers do we
have we've got I think 11 active strike
groups and most other countries have one
m so we're we're pretty dang powerful as
a nation because it's probably more than
just a nation considering but I wonder I
mean does Russia and China enter this
Middle Eastern conflict under the guise
of the us is going to cause nuclear war
by you know and and and mass casualties
and we have to intervene what if what if
Russia and China decide to prevent us
involvement in the conflict entirely
they deploy troops into Syria and and I
don't know about Iran but perhaps I
don't know if that would be the most
strategic location well wasn't wasn't
Israel taking shots at Syria today in
Damascus they were today at the it's
been ongoing non in Syria the Israeli
strikes on Syria been happening for a
decade well sure but I mean just today
there was something specific you saw
today and Lebanon is targeting civilian
communities in Israel I mean this is
Israel evacuated some of the north you
know um yeah but Biden is going to visit
Israel next week now for for all those
who are sit being like I don't care
about War I don't know any about this
stuff like okay well you know your gas
prices are going to quadruple mhm you
know 67 gas yeah a lot of these people
are too young to even remember after 911
what happened with the economy and what
happened with the gas prices and you
know like I don't remember that yeah you
don't I wonder how how the us is going
to this not because I'm young I just I
just I didn't have a car I I only you
weren't affected by these things I I I
have questions buying gas three years
ago have questions about the people who
are currently serving as the Marines who
will be deployed to this region what are
your questions well you know I have to
imagine they're on the younger side
likely gen Z I doubt they're sending a
bunch of 40-year-olds you know so
Millennials like mid to late 30s now on
average with some younger Millennials
down into like the I think what you
could be late 20s and be Millennial
right or no you can yeah yeah so I I I
think it's mostly going to be gen Z so
who who's the kind of person who wants
want to enlist right now someone who
wants to do a lot of Tik Tok dances and
be filmed big on drag queen I've heard
this argument right now well do you guys
know that you can get cosmetic surgeries
if you enlist that's so fun that's so
cool yeah they'll they'll cut your dick
off for you yeah they'll do anything
there's are someone was like saying if
you uh tell the air force that you and
your wife are in a dispute because she
needs a boob job the Air Force will like
well to help your marriage this is come
C I don't know if that's you imagine
telling like Roman soldiers join the
Army and we can cut your dick off for
you I think the the I remember this when
I was you know graduating high school
that uh student loan debt was so crazy
that I knew a lot of people who were not
interested in military service but said
but if I if I enlist I could potentially
get it paid for through the GI and I
need to go to college to see able to
exceed and we've seen that argument sort
of collapse the last last couple years
enrollments down we know enlistment in
military servic is down so ultimately
the the very few
benefits um to to enlisting in in the
army or in any sort of military branch
are not as persuasive as they once were
my question is um are they going to try
and sell it as a rallying point I mean
after 911 we did see a lot of an
increase in military enlistment people
people saw it as their National Duty and
I don't think people feel that sort of
patriotic Pride right now especially you
know do you want to be enlisted under
Biden probably definitely not they've
demonized nationalism completely like
there's there's nobody that's why they
have a hiring crisis because a lot of
them would be like I went to the service
because my father served and my
grandfather served well well fear not
everyone because cbs8 has given us the
fact check that amid the Israel Hamas
War and the deployment of 2,000
additional Marines and sailors into a
region and warships US military draft
not returning amid Israel Hamas War oh
cuz that's that's the question everyone
had already asked I love this pre-b this
is what they call it the Pre-K they call
it a Pre-K I'm not kidding where they
put out a fact check before the story
actually hits for this reason yeah there
just one wondering that if in case you
were wondering I mean it makes sense
that's that's the obvious first question
if if no one is enlisting in the
military partially because no one is
qualified to enlist in the military
that's one of the biggest deterrence
there are people who would want to and
they just don't meet any of the fitness
or mental health requirements so on top
of that we don't have enough people then
the draft is the only way to get around
those standards exactly I I had read a
statistic and I I you can't quote me on
it but it was something like 70% of gen
Z like wouldn't qualify for the military
because every body is sick and everybody
is fat it's sick fat and anxious you go
to Google and has allergies to weird
stuff yes you go to Google and you
search for US military draft and there's
just tons of Articles making sure
everyone knows there will not be a
military draft you want to know what
that makes me for that there's
definitely a draft there's
definitely but how could there not be
this makes me think this makes me think
that they are going to have one but
right now they're telling you no no
we're not going to have them but then
something huge has to happen where
everybody's going to get behind it and
say yeah like another n 11 and they say
oh yeah we to be worse has to be worse
it does absolutely at this point see I
or maybe not with with 9911 the issue
was that Americans felt attack so a
bunch of people were like I've got to do
my duty and defend my nation so they
enlisted little do they know that
they're going to be sent to Iraq and
Afghanistan for nation building projects
but uh the the the people who enlisted
and signed up for this that wasn't
completely Noble and then you have
corrupt powers that beat it be that
exploit manipulate well that was
DeSantis that's when DeSantis signed up
considering that we're in Dire Straits
now militaristically like recruitment
rates are really really low it may not
be it may not be so much
about it it may just be they're going to
force people to do it right with 911 you
had people who are willing to do it if
something like that happens now right we
got all this reporting about open border
and potential Terror attacks with and
and and and the war that's happening in
in the Middle East yeah they might just
be like we have no choice however it
will be they there will have to be
something 911 ask well it would be like
Vietnam remember how I mean there were
so many young men who got called up to
Vietnam who had no idea what they were
doing and ended up just being
essentially massacred like that was a
pretty horrible situation and because we
had a lot of um we had weak nationalism
at the time um and we had a bunch of men
called up who didn't know what they were
doing and I think that the young men we
have now are probably far less qualified
than my father's generation was to go to
Vietnam yeah I mean they regularly fail
Basic Fitness tests I think it's so I
I've been talking to some members of
special ops military forces for story
I'm working on and it's interesting
because if you from the anecdotal
evidence that I have you know people who
want to be in Special Force they want to
be Green Berets they want to be Navy
Seals they tend to be even more Elite
those standards have gone up just
because of who is electing to be a part
of them it's you know division one
athletes it's former professional
athletes people who are in the best
shapes of lives but just the Infantry
which is really what all branches of the
military need these basic levels uh
those standards are lower and they're
regularly missing their recruitment
goals I mean right and the military is
in a position where they are beginning
to sort of alter their reporting numbers
to make it look like they're not doing
as badly as they could as we go into the
brink of World War III I mean it's not a
good position there is no way they don't
end up drafting people if they
ultimately decide we are I do I do think
that there's a difference though as well
like I think that if the United States
were attacked as it was with 911 which
is a different situation than fighting
in Foreign Wars I think that if there
were um you know there's there has been
talk of these some what five million
illegal immigrants who have come into
the us since Biden took office that
there could be Terror cells among them
we have seen the um the the great
numbers of single young men entering the
country with no real Rhyme or Reason as
to what they could possibly be doing
here if we started seeing the kind of
suicide bombings or you know terrorist
attacks that you know Hamas Unleashed on
Israel in what like the late 80s and
into the 90s if we started seeing that
in the US I think that you would see
nationalism go up I think that a lot of
young people would be like I'm going to
fight for America because the the fight
has come to America but I do think that
there is a lot less of an appetite to
send our children to go fight in Foreign
Wars under this idea that we're
protecting democracy when we're watching
our own democracy and our own Nation
fall apart I totally agree I think I
think there would be people who would
say I want to defend America but I think
they would be less likely to enlist and
get deployed far away they would want to
stay close to their families you might
see an increase in like maybe the
National Guard but even that could be
deployed internationally I think people
if we saw an increase in in domestic on
the ground in US tax the desire to
protect would be there I just think it
would be a deterrent from joining the
military and they wouldn't join they
they'd form a militia for a mil if we're
seeing you might people join local law
enforcement but I think the chance that
you could be deployed away from your
family when you know there's an increase
in in domestic it be hard to it would
also be hard to join local law
enforcement the kind of laws that we've
seen enacted against law enforcement
officials um has been pretty grave in
the past several years I mean the the
defund the police movement was
shockingly effective not just in
actually pulling funds by city council
of police departments but changing the
laws across the board we had a report
this morning I came in to work this
morning uh I turned on my phone and I
was at work but I came in this mute is
crazy right it's crazy um but yeah Ari
Hoffman put this report together about
uh this uh 911 call in Seattle that was
made public and on the call it showed
that um there was like a domestic abuse
situation the guy was beating up this
woman she was like trying to get to her
kid and protect her kid or whatever he
drags her into the car uh forces her to
drive she's being pursued by by police
officers and the police officers call
off the pursuit cuz they're like oh
we're not actually allowed to pursue
unless there's probable cause of
something and they're afraid to pursue
that's true I think not just Seattle but
in Chicago I think as well that's what
was going on it's like the police
officers aren't allowed to give chase
after a certain point so the morale has
got to be really low and there are you
know like Police recruitment is Low
Police recruitment is low and that's a
big part of it too like in New York City
they have been you know cutting funds
mayor Adams has been threatening to cut
funds for police officers and kids who
are enlisting and thinking about joining
a militia they do have to know their
constitution well because the government
the federal government does have the
right to call up um call up the militias
to to fight they're that's R but it's
but it's yes and if we if we operate
under the traditional sense of militia
that would matter but all that really
means is conscription cuz militia back
in the day wasn't so organized it was
just the local men in the area would
take up guns and they'd fight if they if
they had to I think what we'd end up
seeing is is if there were taxs in the
United States people would look to their
neighborhood watch or the neighborhood
leaders and just be like tell me where
to stand they wouldn't sign any papers
or do anything formally would make it
really difficult for the US government
well you know that's go ahead J I'm
sorry no it's okay so so really
everything so when it comes to war in
the Constitution it's written on a
defensive stance so it's article 4
section 4 and it it says that it's the
federal government's duty to protect the
states from Invasion and I mean we're in
one there's been declared one you know
but that's really the only that's the
only thing it says doesn't say anything
about offense at all all that that's
interesting about protecting States from
Invasion because so many states have
been Invasion invaded by the federal
government's policies with this illegal
immigration thing like why I I find it
perplexing that states aren't standing
up for themselves more you have New York
City being like hey it's too much well
New York City is like come help us
federal government whereas Greg Abbott
in Texas is like I am invoking my right
to defend
and then they're like stop doing that
immediately stop I think that's the
craziest thing I mean we probably all
followed it for so long but with that uh
floating buoy barrier at first they were
like it's not humanitarian people could
drown he's like yes we should deter them
from swimming and potentially drowning
they're like we've changed our mind you
were supposed to get Congressional
approval and then he was like but no I
don't need that I'm I am here to defend
Texas and I think that's this weird
position the Biden position the Biden
Administration walking in you'll get
them you you know authorizing through
mayorcas uh more construction of the
border wall and then they immediately
walk it back because their policies are
hurting the country and they know they
have to act because not only is New York
suffering but Texas is suffering there
no one is going to stand by them in this
next election cycle if they don't do
something on the other hand they said
they wouldn't uh build the wall and so
they look like Hypocrites because they
are they're only sort of building it and
they're building it not in the necessary
places from what I understand do
anything right but yeah so Chicago
actually had um they had the residents
of Chicago the black the black residents
and they were cuz I guess they're
sending a lot of migrants to Chicago I
love that the black black residents like
no no get out of here they're like we
already get the crumbs and you want the
crumbs of our crumbs like I sort of had
this idea when I saw that when I saw
those people standing up in Chicago I
was like maybe all us Americans can
remember that we're all Americans and
we're all on the same team and we don't
have to like be divided up by these
racial segregated ideas like you know
black Americans are Americans and you
know like white Americans are Americans
and well and illegal immigration Latino
Americans are Americans and like we're
here let's protect our country can we do
that together it used to be a Melting
Pot and the answer is kind of no we I
mean thing is illegal immigration hurts
impoverished communities more because it
adds an additional burden to a community
that's already struggling so it makes
sense to me that people who would feel
as though they are dis Advantage would
then be like please close the border
this is not helping us it's just
marketed as this thing like you're so
you're so mean and they're just coming
here because there is economic turmoil
on their country and ultimately we know
that that's not the case like in slim
cases people are seeking uh Asylum but
it's not the wide majority that the
Biden Administration would like it to be
let's let's and then you're destroying
Queens with a brutal sex trade I have a
proposal we have a story from the
post-millennial and just let me read the
title first for before my proposal for
four Iranian special interest aliens
apprehended by border patrol attempting
to cross into us in October two Lebanese
citizens were also arrested in Eagle
Pass last week all right new rule if
you're going to deploy US military
forces into a region in Conflict you
must lock down your borders oh that's a
good idea I think it's a great idea that
why wouldn't you do that
that why wouldn't you secure your
borders even outside of War if you knew
that there was turmoil in your
neighborhood you'd probably lock your
front door why why are we defending the
borders in Ukraine and defending the
borders in Israel but we're not
defending our own borders no our borders
get to stay open because it's okay if
our citizens suffer we can't let
citizens in other count suffer though
that would be bad fanbo are they coming
in on fan boats have you seen that's fan
there's been some reporting I have them
all over how cool would it be if they're
coming in like hovercrafts you ever see
those they Glide over the water like the
air pressure and the
floats they're reporting from the Daran
Gap it's like these long kayak looking
type
yeah mhm yeah what if they were like
throwing grappling hooks over trees and
Swinging across the river if that's the
caseing H Let's Go lit them in if that's
the case that is unless they have close
the border yeah but if it's that cool
cool but if they paraglide over the
border wait wait what if they swung from
a tree and then when they released they
did back flip I think you guys don't
understand no illegal immigration no
matter how cool even if they're anime
superheroes I also love theatrics But
ultimately I'm not going to give an
exception for the best entry it's the
Cirus Brigade they're just like either
way under the Border it's meritocracy
like like Tim said and our country is
founded on meritocracy so I mean it
checks out it checks out okay but in all
seriousness uh our border is porous and
busted we're deploying troops to go
protect other people's borders and we
have potential War wartime threats to
this country Iranian special interest
it's not saying overt terrorists or
anything like that do you want actually
do you know the story liby I mean it's
your your write it today you know I
didn't write that one actually
everything that goes up on postal every
know everything so here's the point yeah
as lindsy Graham is threatening to bomb
Iran does it look we want to be very
careful about who we're letting into the
country after one of our Senators
threatened to bomb their country right
yeah so the real risk is not we're not
even talking about economics or whether
it's cool how they enter that that's
obviously a big joke the threat is yo
are we letting spies into this country
to attack us yes okay we do that all the
time this is the thing like we under the
guise of being able to say this is a
humanitarian issue we need to be nice we
just let anyone enter so why would
another country not be like we'll just
send some military H men we just will
send a spy because you can get through
the Border this is go ahead no I'm sorry
oh I I can rant about this all day long
I this different this is an addition to
the 151 individuals on the FBI Terror
watch list who have been admitted to the
country since Biden took did they say
that they lost track of like 24
terrorists they lost track of a lot of
people they've lost track of children
who are being now like sold into
domestic sexual slavery absolutely but
that way they get to be here when it
happens like I I just don't understand
this argument for why anyone would
benefit from an open border everyone
suffers and the Biden Administration
passes off is like these there actually
over 70,000 special interest aliens that
they have
encountered what does that mean special
interest are we talking about Terror
threats well let's see what it means
what because I know that we we we've
specifically talked about it's an
illegal alien from a nation that either
promotes terrorist activity Harbors
terrorist or poses a possible security
threat so what that is these are people
who president Donald Trump said we're
not going to let any of these people
into the country and he was called
islamophobic for oh yeah was was this
the Muslim band yeah it oh it was a
Muslim band it was the Muslim band was a
Muslim band Plus North Korea and
Venezuela and today North Korea capital
of the world the disantis campaign
started being like when is Trump going
to talk about what he would do about
terrorist illegal immigrants and it's
like what you mean how about what he did
he doesn't have to talk about what he
would do he policies and he did things
when he was in office he kept people out
no no he recently did and he did he
posted a meme of crocodiles and today
also an
OTE yeah Greg Abbott's like please send
the crocodiles I don't know if the
crocodiles could survive cuz if they
could they' just be there already would
ruin vacationing in the Gulf honestly a
few crocodiles would just saave this off
we know to stay away from the water in
Florida like Ben Ben made a great Point
uh earlier about he said the West
doesn't need to commit suicide to
protect refugees you might want to pay
attention to who you're letting into
your country it doesn't mean we blame
citizens and civilians in Conflict he
was like we're not going to blame the
the civilians in in in Palestine but
we're not going to open the door just
let everyone come in countries the Arab
countries aren't letting in these
refugees Egypt's not Egypt's not you
know and also there's no reason that we
should you have what's his name jabal
jbal Bowman in New York saying that we
should take in Palestinian refugees from
Gaza the the fire alarm P I would trust
a guy on on that who doesn't even know
what a fire alarm well I frankly would
probably not trust anyone from Brooklyn
I'm take from that and she can say that
because she's from New York she lived in
Brooklyn it's not a hate crime so aren't
there standards for Asylum and they're
just like rubber stamping everybody
instead of like being like no you don't
meet the requirement for Asylum so maybe
they should just start enforcing rules
that exist you know we have have to
combine the previous segment with this
segment we don't have enough people to
fight in our armies and so we import all
these illegal immigrants and then we say
that's right that's right hey you want
citizenship all you got to do is fight
for us I we did it before in Civil War
Irish but but it it is common they offer
non-citizens of path citizen Ship by
serving in the armed forces true that's
pretty I mean that's not just an
American thing that's a classic thing
throughout history that have done isn't
that how n like like didn't Rome do
something like that before collapsing
Rome did yeah well we did that in the
Revolutionary War I believe and the
civil war war well the Revolutionary War
was French intervention the the crown
had the mercenaries French right right
right they had like the hessin I
remember that story we can't ask people
who came here illegally to become
citizens you guys are crazy that would
be ridiculous I'm not on board with this
plan either I think that we should
probably have something like that's the
policy huge levels of deportations and
just be like no you're done like this is
not going to work out entire Rosevelt
hotel and just like move out deportation
but to Ukraine I just think the Biden
Administration doesn't want to offer
citizenship and they don't want to offer
a p like they like that there's me
what's going on is it's not that they
don't want to offer citizenship they do
want to offer citizenship they're just
going to do all of this incrementa
incrementally they're doing it slowly
just one little tiny step at a time so
that the next one seems inevitable and
then the next thing seems inevitable and
then the next thing you know we have 5
million new citizens because they had an
amnesty didn't Reagan do an amnesty
they're going to have like an agreement
where it says like you know sign up for
the US armed forces or go fight in
Ukraine and you will earn citizenship
and there'll be like an asterus next to
it then at the bottom of the page it'll
be like C addendum 5e which is not
attached to this contract and then when
you search the like the the paperwork
online it'll be like citizen of Ukraine
right I'm okay with offering illegal
immigrants off uh citizenship in Ukraine
that seems fine to me uh mean argue what
what if what if the I mean honest
question I still think it's probably bad
but what if the US was like we're going
to take all the illegal immigrants and
send them to go fight in Ukraine well
does a does one country people would
stop coming yeah I think they would I
think zinsky would be mad because he'd
be like no you haven't trained them
properly and now I have this population
of people who don't really know how to
fight and it's kind of an ethn State you
know what are we supposed to say well
but you got to you got to just do you
got to take the uh the the Soviet
approach which was I might add
appropriated by zap branagan in the
future in Futurama as a joke where you
just send wave after wave of your own
men to die and eventually overwhelm the
opposing force and I'm not kidding
that's literally the Soviet method
that's what they've done every time yeah
the Soviets just like effective just
take a bunch of lowquality garbage and
just smash it in that direction isn't
that what China does too basically yeah
and then the Nazis in World War II were
like we want the best technology the
premium and then I'm doing yeah then
when it blows up you have you have like
10 tanks they're really great and then
eventually one goes down the Russians
were like mass produced the wor they're
now they're making they've turned some
of their factories over to like full
tank manufacturing jez they did that
they did that months and months ago in
fact yeah it's true I think I think we
covered that at human events.com look
with with these stories that we're
getting these these horror horror
stories like the guy who killed the
six-year-old kid the kid died right the
kid died that guy looks like a total
crazy man too but but I I I I think
we're going to he was he was a landlord
was the landlord oh I'm being very
bigoted that was the opposite he wasn't
Not only was he not homeless but he
owned more home yeah he could have voted
during the colonial period I think I
think we're going to see some kind of
like major terror attack in the next
year I believe I agree with you what
they're what they're doing right now
it's kind of a process that they use to
capture different countries it's
demoralization destabilization crisis
and normalization and usually they kind
of do it in order they're like just
demoralize everybody and then they
destabilize everybody and then they
create a chaos and and then they
normalize it but what we're seeing
America do is throw it all throw it all
down and see what sticks so they're
normalizing parts of the chaos and
they're demoralizing everybody to
destabilize them while they're
destabilized their more demoralization
and it's just and that's why Everything
feels so chaotic because it is we feel
like we're moving in fast forward it
does feel very very quick it feels like
weeks take months you know I can't
believe it's mid October already y
That's crazy we like we go to Miami for
a week it's like 80° outside where
skating is so hard we come back from
Miami and now it's 40 45 de that was a
great show by the way congrats was a
terrific event we're thinking we're
thinking we're going to do uh Pittsburgh
in March PS because it's so easy to just
drive there it is easy to drive there I
watched somebody lose like $119,000 at a
blackjack table in casinos are in
Pittsburgh Tim we can go there casinos
everywhere hereas I watched a guy lose
like 50 Grand in 10 minutes and he
didn't seem to care and I'm just like oh
this guy seemed like he was getting uh
increasingly angry but who really looked
upset with his wife who just like looked
terrified that was a scary moment she's
like this is not a fun vacation to
Pittsburgh great I I think they live
there I'm excited for a Pittsburgh show
be interesting that sounds great ladies
and gentlemen we may uh uh have some we
have some breaking news here I'm seeing
this this was just tweeted out by Jesse
Waters take a look Joe Biden to visit
Israel on Wednesday didn't I say this
like 20 minutes ago that he was that Joe
Biden was going there yeah tomorrow oh
okay W you said it quietly you didn't
announce it cool radio host voice Monday
he's going there Wednesday right he's
going there Wednesday wait it's not
Tuesday it's not Tuesday it's impossible
to say what day it is um sorry everyone
it seems like a really bad idea for Joe
Biden to be going to an active conflict
Zone when Rockets are blowing up but
maybe that's the plan yeah maybe this is
your Gavin Newsome Rises to the occasion
moment I was kind of thinking that yeah
and I mean that this this is than 911
lose our president it does seem like it
could be kind of a setup it could be the
you know well let's think about this how
do you get rid of kamla Harris everyone
says if Joe Biden bows out kamla's next
in line she has to run is she going with
him there what I'm not saying that I'm
saying what if Joe Biden you know God
forbid something bad happens when he's
over in Israel which is the C belly for
us intervention in the region Kamala
Harris assumes the role Office of the
presidency and then steps down at the
end of the term and it and and it goes
to a new candidate oh I see there one
way that feasibly Kam Harris drops out
is that she actually serves and then
says I I did my duty and now I'm going
to be stepping down I think she would
drop out I think that she would be
unburdened by What Might Have Been I was
going to say stick it out I think it it
would we're talking about the CIA a very
intense internal battle because I think
she would not want to give up the shot
at first I completely disagree I don't
think she would win think she wouldn't
want to go she's a muppet she's just
like clearly the lady can't talk have
you ever heard her a spe she say the
same thing over and over and over again
she really doesn't want to be there no
she she laughs and says nonsense she got
and so if if the plan from our
intelligence apparatus was to get in a
new a new candidate who is going to
actually be able to inspire to some
degree it ain't kamla and Kam is not
going to do it because they're going to
tell her no Joe Biden is here now and
it's not so much about Joe Biden not
being a part of the deep state or or the
bureaucratic State or the administrative
State it's that you need a clean PR exit
if Joe Biden goes I'm too old I got to
go everyone's going to say okay what
about Kam
we also know she can't win right if
something bad happens to Biden deep
state gets its War it cass's belly KLA
Harris then assumes the role for the
next year and or year and a half and
then says I did my duty I'm now going to
hand it off to those who are more
capable y yada yada and honorably hands
the the passes the torch down to
somebody else and she she served as vice
president first female whatever she
wants to identify as vice president
sometimes it's Asian sometimes it's
black first female president yep first
one yep and she also got to serve for
like one day as president because Joe
Biden had to go under anesthesia for
like a colon right so so she already was
the first president that was female so
so it's all out of the way it's gotten
out of the way so she doesn't have to
serve now because she's already been one
but assuming the role for a short period
would be like legitimately hitting that
hitting that marker I think it's the
ideal case for her and I think it just
depends on how entrenched she is in uh
obeying her commanders right I I
if she's the thing about Biden is that I
think he does not want to go he will put
up a fight he wants to retain power for
as long as possible maybe Kamala is more
compliant and she would exit after you
know half a term or whatever she has
left to serve I just think all of these
people are so power hungry that once
they get into the chair they don't want
to leave it I believe that she can serve
for two full terms after the midpoint so
she serve for 10 years how many people
in this country would support us
intervention into the Middle East
particularly the is Israel region Israel
Jordan Etc how many people would support
that if Joe Biden was critically wounded
by Hamas yep or Hezbollah or Iran yeah
Iran yeah I mean look I'll I'll I'll say
right now I I imagine all of the neolibs
are going to outright be in favor of it
we are all going to find ourselves
sharing talking points with many
leftists who are anti-war not because
they agree with us but because they will
exploit whatever the the the modern the
modern narrative is to gain power and if
their support is for Palestine we will
all say something like foreign
intervention is a mistake it'll cause
World War III and they'll parot those
talking points in an effort to try and
seize power you will then get someone
like Ben Shapiro who will undoubtedly
say they they this is these are
terrorists who have killed Israelis and
now they've targeted our president and
this Administration the US absolutely
must must you're going to get every
conservative like 90% of conservatives
saying that the US must intervene I
think there would be huge support for
military intervention if they went after
the president but it does seem
ridiculous that we're putting the
president in directly In Harm's Way yeah
it is ridiculous are exploding over T
right now he wouldn't go to what paline
Ohio but he will go here like what is
going on B why he also won't go to the
Border still I don't understand this
risk management why is one thing okay
when we know there is very violent
active conflict but the other plac is
that they kept saying no it's fine he
won't go this doesn't make sense y also
I think blinkin is in
charge barely yeah but like it seems
like it I think he's the one who's
making all the all of these decisions
and he was just in talks for seven hours
so I I mean now we need Biden to come in
Biden are a very effective and
charismatic leader so he can like fall
off the stage in Jerusalem instead of
rough I don't like this it just we look
so I'm worried more than stage I'm
worried about Rockets exploding the Iron
Dome failing MH it's almost like he's
intentionally being set up yes how could
you not feel that way that's what it
looked like to me earlier today and I
was like no that's crazy don't think
that remember what Obama said to Joe you
don't have to do this right what he was
really saying is Joe don't don't
sacrifice yourself for this country
going back to how many people would be
in favor of of uh something if the if it
happened to the president I mean I think
Congress had something like a 90%
approval rating when it came to 911 and
everybody was just so in favor War so in
favor of the Patriot Act so in favor of
justice and Redemption and and so I
think that it wouldn't be that high but
I think it' be probably like 70% you
know if we can kind of think about how
what percentage of conservatives would
be behind it what percentage of neol
lives would be behind it we could
probably get a pretty rough estimate
about it's a legitimately difficult
question would would any any of us here
would any of you watching let's let's
not let's not enter like let's say Joe
Biden on good on good faith let's say on
good faith is trying to actually
deescalate and he's going there to tell
them Joe Biden's already publicly stated
he they should not invade Gaza so okay
let's say on good faith Joe Biden really
is trying to
deescalate if
Hamas attacks and and in any way removes
Joe Biden I'll be very light on my
language would you listening comment
below let me what you think support us
intervention to go after those who
committed the act that that you know
targeted our
president either one could really use
another fool around and find out tweet
from Donald
Trump what if Donald Trump then says as
much as we think Joe Biden look we think
he's crooked but and then he decides we
are going after the terrorists has he
what has he has how has he been on
Israel or even Ukraine for that he he
just put out a statement saying he will
not allow the refugees or the these
people coming he still seems America
First he's very America first but he's
also he's also said that he stands with
BB
and he said I stand with BB and I stand
with Israel so you know I do think that
he does Israel is a long-standing Ally
and um you know I'm I'm fully in support
of Israel's right to defend themselves I
will say if if if our president were
assassinated by a a foreign agent on
foreign soil I would recommend literally
destroying whatever nation was behind
it's the most impossible situation
because you want to be at least I would
like to be as anti- inist America First
is this anti-interventionist that's
retaliatory it's retaliatory at that
point and that's that's the difference
I'm good if we can just keep the kids
out of it yeah true but everyone in the
chat is saying no way no no way no us
retaliation if we have no retaliation to
a presidential assassination by a
foreign agent then we have no Nation
because we're we're involved in a very
different way than we are right now if
our president were assassinated on
foreign soil by the
CIA uh this is kind of what we're where
we're at
now has discovered oil in the US be
deploying a military force to liberate
the us from the
US yeah it's good one yeah that checks
out I mean there are there are you know
organizations in the world that really
hate the United States and want to see
us destroyed fully one of those is Hamas
like I mean I wonder if people would be
saying if Donald TR like here's another
question if Joe Biden was sitting in the
White House and the White House got
attacked and foreign agents you know
took the life of Joe Biden in the house
should there be a a
retaliation article section 4 that's
what our military is there for very
defense of our na what about Ron Paul
had the view that we should issue
letters of Mark Mark and reprisal those
to Target specifically the actors who
did it and not declare war on entire
nations right so when it came to 911 his
argument was Al-Qaeda did this it's not
Iraq it's not Afghanistan we should have
issued letters of Mark in reprisal and
gone after Al-Qaeda specifically mhm so
so if anybody doesn't really know what
letters of Mark it's it's in the
Constitution it's like something article
something Section 8 Clause 11 um it's
it's essentially that they can make
Americans mercenaries or make Americans
honorary Pirates essentially the
honorary pirate Clause okay so so if we
get in a sea war or a land war with
Russia or China or Iran or whatever um
the Congress can write these letters of
Mark and say oh you own a boat you get
to be a pirate now and then you get to
go be a pirate it yeah yeah that's after
911 theyed a fireboat and there's
actually more to this Clause too or how
they've interpreted it like you get to
take their booty and and but you have to
split the booty with Congress that was
kind of the original reading of the
letters of Mark Nancy Pelosi's got to
get hers get a boat this is what people
don't realize Pirates were were
basically under Crown protection during
Like Pirates of the Caribbean you Barber
Pirates I mean but it it just there were
so many more right the that Britain
basically says hey go go disrupt French
supply lines and we'll protect you and
then when France is like you're
attacking our ships like oh those are
pirates never I think John Adams
actually uh it was John Adam yep against
the barber the barbery Pirates yeah he
was really he was working on
negotiations with them yeah it was a
whole big thing to just try and get
their ships to to get across yeah so
they could trade well after the uh war
for independence the uh uh Britain was
still
kidnapping capturing US citizen and
forcing them to serve on their ships
crazy anyway in the in in the effect uh
in the instance that something does
happen to Joe Biden so here's a question
if so if Joe Biden goes overseas and
something happens to him people have
mostly said no no no we should not
intervene because of that what if it's
Donald Trump what if Donald Trump went
to North Korea to negotiate peace
crossed the DMZ and then once he got up
you know 50 feet in they bashed him over
the head and dragged his body off to a
prison should the us then go to war with
North Korea even if it means CH and then
I don't think we should go to war with
North Korea I think we should destroy
North Korea and then China says if you
make any moves on North Korea we will
nuke New York I would still say then we
nuke them too that's World War II well
we're heading there anyway if they
destroy our if they kill our president
we're already there yeah I was going to
say the president thing is is a level of
Engagement from the other side that we
are not currently at can we encourage
them everyone say bomb Hollywood on top
of New York City I mean can we can we
like about yeah we get the children outb
the movie Remember The Simpsons hallowen
special with K and kotos and they're
like we'll take all we'll we'll take all
of your members of Congress and then
Homer Homer Mar like you couldn't get
all of them could you ah just watch us
and they're like all right can we help
yeah like oh no don't yeah I was going
to say I wonder what the simpons have
predicted about this well a lot of a lot
of people are saying if if Donald Trump
was was attacked or targeted yes we
should intervene so it's it's more of a
political question than than anything
else but I think that's the problem like
as much as I don't like Biden he is
still the president so if another
country you know attacked him on foreign
soil it is still a serious crime against
America it hasn't happened I don't know
why we are sending Biden there it is
stupid it is just very stupid do make
any sense this is my concern I mean
there's look man you can be as anti-
intervention as you want but you're
going to you're going to convince there
there's a lot of people are going to be
like yeah killing a president is is
grounds for Invasion yeah yes I fully
think if like if anything anything is
ground for reprisal it is quite
literally killing our president yes I
fully agree with that that's terrifying
Biden should not be going to a conflict
Zone like this right now it's very
stupid makes no sense it's suppos to was
too dangerous right no it wasn't
dangerous I just didn't want to go it
doesn't make any sense fa the border is
probably too dangerous yeah true well
apparently it's not as dangerous as this
situation so I don't really know what
they're communicating to us I I I think
this is the weird thing about the
theatrics of the Biden Administration is
that nothing is logical nothing makes
sense and so you have to sort of suspend
trying to make it reasonable uh and
that's why we can have these
conversations that are like are they
setting him up because it seems like
they might be because logic it does seem
really bizarre to send your president to
an active war zone like this where
you're deploying your Marines right but
everything is and where there's like
active terrorists seeking to destroy the
nation that he is going to visit mhm is
he got to be guarded by all those
Marines
and are they going to like send the
Marines over with Biden and then just
leave the Marines there is that
essentially what's happening maybe well
the Marines are already in the area
aren't they already like not in the US
they're nearby are reporting we've got a
lot of guys in Germany right they were
in Kuwait yeah many of them were in
Kuwait I don't know where these other
guys are coming from but uh yeah we're
sending 2,000 troops and the president's
heading there you know this doesn't bode
well did he did he go to Maui in the end
or did he not Maui I'm going to go hang
out in the store room with all my food
buckets and just you know turn the
lights off went to Maui cuz that's a
good question too I mean that was the
other one Biden he did go to Maui Yeah
Tim did he was on vacation
in Utah maybe uh what's the lake there
uh Tahoe Tahoe he was on vacation in
Tahoe and he took a morning and an
afternoon maybe I think and went to Maui
oh wow nice him he and a little and
Biden didn't go to New York on 911 he
went to Alaska but to be fair New York
is is too dangerous for the president he
didn't go to 911 but he said he went to
n he went to New York on
911 in 2001 even though he didn't he
went with a little Congressional
Delegation a few days after because he
was literally in Congress giving a
speech and there's video of it well I
mean to be fair you know a lot of it is
that he's just a liar and he's always
been but he do also does have like and I
mean it's quite literally like serious
brain damage from like aneurysms and
surgery so as it's not funny I mean it's
true this is of our country that we are
now being like hey everyone on the brink
of tension so let's send Joe Biden in to
put things what I hate this little old
man walk when he walks around he's going
to walk dementia Shuffle is sad but it's
like it's not what I would like and a
president that is that is probably the
better point that of all the people we
need to be sending to Israel to like
talk down the war we're sending the
worst it doesn't make sense it's like we
want to get things to get worse may we
should CIA is like go I think that
they're doing it in the same way because
so many people are invested in in in
this this war and it's almost like it's
it's almost like when George W bush went
to 9 to 911 and put his armor on the
firefighter and I think they they think
they're going to get something like that
they are not yes exactly did did Biden
ever go to Ukraine I know the first lady
went to Ukraine at one point K Harris
went too K Harris went did but did Joe
Biden go to Ukraine I don't remember
Boris Johnson went yeah he did he did go
to Ukraine I think Biden oh Biden went
and there were like fake Air Sirens they
they like set off air raid sirens and no
one looked at all urbed because they
were or something he went this year like
a year into the conflict he went yeah he
went after but and he went he waited
some good time for this thing that we
spent billions of dollars also went ke
which is different than if Biden was
kidnapped and and smuggled into tan and
they put him on camera and they had him
and they were like we have your
President should the US invade Iran we
don't negotiate with terrorists also
immedi Jo immediately defund the Secret
Service who clearly did a terrible job
or was compli all right yep yeah there
if he gets kidnapped I'm sorry but that
just a waste of money I'm just asking
this hypothetical in in in like would
people support a US invasion of Iran if
they kidnap our president the chat
saying about that the chat uh uh
everyone's saying give Kamala a pay
raise no no no no how dare you I think
obviously okay what about Trum to do
what we could to protect our president
Trump would not want us to negotiate
with terrorists that's some of his ads
is that Jo Biden negotiates with
terrorists and look what happened and
he's like I don't negotiate with
terrorist you
imagine go get him but also Trum get out
they have Trump in like a chair and he's
tied up Trump they put a camera on and
they're like if you don't give us you
know5 billion we you know if you give if
you want your president release and then
Trump rips The Mask up he's like don't
do it don't give him anything and they
hit him and then he's like no and then
you know like a movie no he probably
just get elected in that country you
know like he's so charismatic they be
like it's making some great points this
New Yorker like can you be our president
say yes to Trump if it's Trump we go in
bid no the issue is that B it's not
about Biden or Trump it's about the
representative of our nation yeah that's
ultimately what comes down to I
understand it's on us that we have a
super just an awful
represent leader of our nation that's
humiliating it is yeah it's on us that
we don't have an inspirational president
who we want to go sa I don't even want
an inspirational president I just want
someone who can think thoughts all the
way through from from beginning to end
to good decisions and project confidence
and a little bit of insanity at the rest
of the world I remember something they
used someone who falls upstairs I
remember something that they used to do
with Trump when he would go and meet
with foreign leaders and they'd be like
look at you know these people don't
respect him at all and they'd be like
like Justin Trudeau like like you know
all femininely looking him up and down
do you want Justin trau to respect you
though exactly right this is the thing
and every be like yeah see the the
foreign world doesn't respect Donald
Trump it's like really like like can can
we do can we can we talk about Joe Biden
now can we talk about the respect no one
respects Joe Biden at all not at all no
they're like not even his wife who let
him run for president no no God no yeah
they don't respect him at all they I
mean The Border's wide open like
everybody lit their prisoners out to
come to our country the minute he got an
office I mean you can track it right
down to January 20th or whatever the to
the El Salvador president who put all
those guys in prison so that they're
crossing the B that dude's that dude's
inting out of the ballpark man yeah
definitely El Salvador's killing it mhm
yeah I mean literally Trump like not
Trump but Biden's been disrespected to
his face like he landed in China that
time and they just didn't meet him there
as they didn't have the delegation there
and he sat there oh well I guess like
they'll figure it out did the same thing
to Trump trump just turned on the left
immediately because you realized that
they're it's a big disc bro it's not
really cool yeah yeah so yeah they don't
for someone who got criticized for not
being presidential he would not have
taken these diplomatic SNS exactly man
I'm really worried about Wednesday yeah
there there's there's so I mean with the
investigations into the bidens M if
something bad happens to him there's no
political circumstance in which people
are going to be all of it gone all the
underbid stuff gone all the Joe Biden
bisma Ukraine all of it gone anything
bad happens to him it it's dude they're
like sacrificing their Queen in chess
you know what I'm saying this is what it
feels like oh it is it's the queen
sacrifice interesting if you if you
think he's like a person that can move
anywhere on the board and do all these
things I don't think he move himself I
think someone else makes the decision
which is how it works with chess cuz he
needs somebody else's hand he is yeah
he's perceived as the most powerful
person in the United States like the
queen you know protects the king but is
the king the Deep state who's the king
we don't have a king yeah the Deep State
yeah and they say it's time for you to
go byen to to serve your country this is
what you need to and that's the thing
because he'll kind of go down if
something God forbid happens like nobody
wants that to happen nobody wants so
nobody would wish that but if something
God forbid you know happen but it gives
the Deep State literally
everything
bad could like come of that and this
move him going to Israel this doesn't
track like I said no border he didn't go
to Ohio he won't even go to New York but
he he he went to Ukraine after a year of
conflict but he puts a l on and he's
like I'm going to Israel immediately it
doesn't make sense that was the Monday
after this war started he put a lid on
it by like 11:54 a.m. but they were
still kind of putting out statements
right they were sort of vaguely I mean
you had kjp there on Twitter doesn't
make any sense she is the worse yeah she
is but they'll stick by her that's I was
kind of expecting her to not she's a
lesbian so they have to stick by her
because she is a diversity hire because
of her sexual orientation and they they
put gender identity and who you like to
sleep with as the most important
qualifiers for how you get a job in the
Biden Administration did you ever think
you'd Miss Jen that was my question
uh no but I kind of do sometimes I I
don't watch her show though no I don't
watch I don't miss that much this I this
just a
add on to this briefly before we jump on
the next story it is so weird the
obsession with sex the left has where
it's like exactly what you're saying you
have these these hires where it's like
okay and the job is crane operator and
who do you sleep with yeah it's like uh
and so I'll just add to this because uh
you guys know I've been playing balers
gate modern video game triaa game comes
out every character is trying to trying
to have sex with with your characters
like you have four different characters
you have a party and you play as each
one of them each have their own story
line but it's basically the whole game
makes literally no sense because of it
and it's really annoying and people have
been complaining about it but what
happens is with this wokeness they're
like anybody can have a relationship
with anybody but it's just like the
problem is when I'm going like on a on a
on a job right like we go to Miami we're
going to go to Miami and we're going to
go down and put on a show the idea that
everyone will be constantly trying to
just like the only conversations you're
having about how you trust and love and
want to have sex with each other is just
like the weirdest thing imaginable also
seems really icky and kind of like it
makes everything awkward Yes Men
everyone in the game is racist in the
game like that's like explicit like
people in the game are racist so it's
it's like just sex and racism huh I I
don't mean to bring up just this one G
my point is left popular culture when it
comes to the workplace professional when
it comes to entertainment is the most
important thing is who you're banging
yeah that's the weirdest thing I always
thought it was weird I have friends who
work for some big you know Corporate
America type companies and they will be
like oh yeah I got you know I I've come
out and so therefore I got put on our
lgbtq whatever panel and I help organize
trainings at work and there's sort of
this weird industry that all hinges on
the fact that you have disclosed who
you're sleeping with or what your sexual
habits are why would you want that
especially in some sort of structural
corporate like this must be an HR
nightmare somewhere down the line well
let's let's jump to this story from the
Daily Mail and talk about victories
against wokeness the inadvertent results
of uh what we're seeing now with Israel
and and Hamas billionaires who have
pumped $500 million to Ivy League
schools back out over failure to condemn
the Hamas Terror attacks on Israel
Harvard and upen face losing hundreds of
millions in future endowments up to 487
million could be lost amid Rising
tensions between Israel and Palestine
billionaires Ken Griffin has requested
Harvard take a robust stance in defense
of Israel so uh let's just put it this
way we've long talked about uh defunding
universities it's happening and it's
happening because the these activist
groups came out in support of terrorists
oh there you go they had a line
apparently there was a line but they
created they created these people they
created these monsters these this is
this is Dr Frankenstein they created
this and now they're like oh I guess
this isn't very popular now time to undo
the damage and look like Heroes that's
crazy Ken Griffin pledged $300 million
to Harvard this year alone but contacted
the head of the University board to
complain about the tepid response of
President Claudine gay
so he's apparently not hearing back and
it looks like they're going to start
pulling pulling their funding the the
claing gay thing was really fascinating
because she put out so you had all of
these student groups at Harvard what was
it like 12 student groups and they all
submitted letters basically in support
of Hamas and like against Israel and
they all put out these letters um and
then you had these companies these CEOs
were like who is who is in these student
groups we don't want to hire them and
then you had like Alum and trustees you
know know complaining and saying you
know we want to pull our funding out you
had Claudine gay the president of
Harvard saying which I think she's right
to say is that she supports Free Speech
she supports the free speech of the
students at the school right I'm always
going to support the Free Speech even
though I totally disagree with it she
came out and said that but this is at a
university where people get deplatformed
for not using the right pronouns or for
saying that men aren't women so it's a
total hypocritical grift is exactly what
it is it's trash Free Speech when it's
when it convenient for her she she
supports Free Speech because she doesn't
have to say anything about these student
groups and she doesn't have to say
anything about the you know crazy
ideological warfare that's been waged
against the students of the United
States making them believe that
terrorism is good and America is bad
right um she doesn't have to do anything
legitimate she just has to like so I I I
support the defunding of these
universities I have long thought that
the problem with the student loan crisis
say the the schools should pay it off
with their huge endowments yes yes
absolutely I agree with that and just
it's sad for me like just as a
constitutional person to think about how
far how far Harvard has fallen like John
Adams went there you know John Quincy
Adams went there like I mean now just
but it hasn't been
that the Springfield Army used to be in
Massachusetts and it isn't now John
Adams also he defended the British
soldiers during the Boston Massacre
which I have immense respect for yes yes
so John even though he totally disagreed
with them he he believed so powerfully
that that they would get a free trial if
they were defended well cuz that's
that's what people were like okay so he
believed so powerfully in this that he's
like I will defend them myself and his
defense got there were eight of them his
defense got six of them off and two of
them instead of death were marked with
an m and that M just meant manslaughter
um yeah so and that and that was his
doing that did that and now it's like we
are we are we are oh my God I loved him
but we were like I love that you have a
John Adams thing I have a John Adams
thing I do have you ever seen Adams uh
no watch it it's the best series ever um
so but I 1776 on Bradway so if you think
about how far away we are yes so if you
think about how far away we are from
from that from John Adams representing
the red coats and getting six of them
off and two of them from death to a
manslaughter brand on their hand now
look at like the J
Sixers yeah and the fact that the same
judge Jud shutkin who has been
Prosecuting January 6 defendants uh
sometimes imposing sentences greater
than the Department of Justice even
asked for is now um the the judge
presiding over Trump's case I think is
absolutely insane she has so much bias
against him um she's she's being allowed
to do this she put a gag order on him
today because they don't like his social
media posts they yeah because they don't
want him to make fun of them right but
also they don't want him to be able to
speak in his own defense and they know
that the more he does speak in his own
defense and the more they prosecute him
the more popular he becomes in the
United
States to talk about Free Speech now
well I have a conspiracy about this I
feel like they are doing this totally
illegally totally in front of our faces
totally unconstitutionally and I it's
going to go to scotus who's going to be
like this was really unconstitutional
what you did we are overturning this you
know he get him off of house arrest
because he's never going to go to prison
unless they build a new Wing or whatever
but he's going to go to Mar Lago have a
ankle bracelet or whatever but they're
going to say okay this is
unconstitutional and then Congress is
going to rise up or all the Deep State
and they're going to be like this is why
we need to pack the court because this
court is bias for Trump and and and
that's the only way to correct this ill
these are Trump judges that Lit him off
and it is undemocratic and that's that's
what's going to happen which means we
can't lose the house yes yes
exactly and it's the only control that
there is and we don't have a speaker
this this this segment is supposed to be
a white pill and you know you guys are
you guys do you guys like Jordan what
who who do you like for speaker h i mean
Matt Gates you like Gates fors speaker I
don't think he's right of course I mean
so well no I don't think he wants to do
it and there's reasons why it it's not
necessarily appropriate I mean he led
the charge against McCarthy but come on
how many people are
actually doing anything Jim Jordan's
great MH but I mean you're still going
to get he's not perfect now nobody is
he's better than he's a big talker he he
talks a big big talk big talk but he
doesn't always walk the walk so well he
has a lot of Investigations that he's
working on yeah appreciate it yeah I
think he could do a good job I think we
have to get someone I think this has
been fun in games but it's time to get a
speaker in place and if it's Jim Jordan
then what about care a speaker can be
anybody like who would you nominate for
speaker Tim Trump yeah okay who would
you nominate liby if I was nominating
for someone for
speaker um I would have to look into it
a little more I don't I would not
nominate Trump for speaker because I
would like him to be president and I
don't he can be that what he can be so
he's going to fight five cases against
him four of which are Criminal once he's
speaker those cases probably evaporate
yeah those cases go away uh I would
nominate Ron Paul would I don't see him
as as I mean Ron Paul's interesting we'd
love to see him do stuff I do think that
he's old enough now where maybe wouldn't
be effective look I believe he will just
live forever and and and preside over
our country in our hearts and in our
minds but uh this is sort of the the
argument uh against people being too old
and being forced to work forever I think
that's not actually good for American
culture um like Diane Feinstein was
working literally she Di and is this
like yeah I think that's gross I really
hope that when I'm that when I'm like
substantially younger than the age Diane
Feinstein was when she died I just get
to like hang out with grandbabies yeah
this is what this is what I pray for I
think this is what bothers me about
American politicians is you know feinste
didn't get into the Senate until she was
60 anyways right so then she was in for
essentially four decades and died while
serving I don't think that that sets a
good precedent for the culture that they
are writing into the law right we need a
culture that supports a work life
balance and promotes people to spend
time with their families I don't like M
Romney but I do understand why he was
like I'm going to be in my mid 80s if I
run again maybe someone else should do
this job um and so with speaker of the
house I would love to see someone young
enough Ron Paul would be great a a
disciple of Ron Paul perhaps I just
can't name one off top of my head I
think it's one of those things have
Smith carefully research Dave Smith Dave
Smith can be speaker of the house but he
doesn't that would be great he'd be
roasting these people the G and being
like you know it could be awesome yeah
it could be good I kind of like Jordan I
just think we have to do someone at this
point you know look if we're if if if
we're going like pie in the sky make
your wishes come true it's
not Jo Jo but I mean you want somebody
who knows how I mean be the house
Speaker the house Speaker has to be an
operator whether we like it or not like
that's part of the job have you ever
seen the meme explaining like what the
Joe ran podcast is and it's like it's
like a breakdown of it's like it's like
basically a script written out Joe's
like he mentioned something about
peanuts growing in trees and then
someone says peanuts don't grow in trees
actually grow underground and he goes
wait what what do you mean and it's like
Jamie pull that up and then he's like
whoa peanuts grow underr he's like yes
pean he's like wow and then he says
something like he's like the the meme is
he goes yeah they they couldn't grow on
trees because squirrels would F them up
could you imagine that squirrels would
be effing up peanut trees squirrels are
basically like little
chimps it would make cpan so interesting
if Joe Rogan was it be the most nobody
would turn it off there's a reason why
he's got the you should be lobbying for
Joe Rogan to be speaker of the house if
you want your ratings to go and then get
some get some new ad deals go Suddenly
It's legitimately ocy depends on what do
we want do we want an entertaining time
or do we want a productive time and
maybe Joe Rogan would be productive
tell just want I really want the borders
closed I want to what Trump would be
really entertaining too on top of it all
would anybody is why Trump trump because
Trump no one's going to be able to go
against him Trump's going to come out
and be like we need to impeach Biden who
wants to run against Donald Trump you
you're going to go up for re-election in
a year and you're going to be the one
guy who said I told Trump no but the
Senate wouldn't take up any of the
legislation that they passed and it
would never get past the the president's
death there's still subpoena power
there's he's going to be like
investigate and yes and Jim Jordan is he
gonna do it
maybe had a thing today Donald Trump
will say I want subpoenas on these
people and then the the moderate
Republicans they call them will have to
go back to the districts and say we told
Trump no knowing Trump's approval rating
and his and his polling levels they're
all going to be like I can't take that
risk unless they want to join the
Democratic party true which many of them
might well not many I'd say maybe a
handful would be like fine I guess I'm a
Democrat now I really don't think so
it's all going the other direction yeah
I think they don't even change their
party they just become because because
what they did they made they made it
like these are the the way that they
they break up magga Republican versus
every other Republican it's to be like
no you can be a republican you can be
Adam kinzinger and you can be Liz Cheney
but you cannot be Matt Gates like this
is the difference that's the line that's
too far yes they right they write you
know articles there I think the New York
Times you probably pull it up wrote an
article about the difference between
Republicans and Maga Republicans just
like a tutorial so you knew what was
good Republican what was bad Republican
but this is a divide and conquer
technique this is well yeah because they
want to maintain the unip party that's
what it's really all about let's let's
go back to the culture War stuff cuz we
had that that white pill article I want
to read you this article make things
happy we got big news deadline reports
the daily wire is making a liveaction
Snow White movie starring conservative
YouTuber Brett Cooper watch the teaser
uh it's for their I think bent key is
their children's streaming service
conservative Media Company daily wires
making its own life action adaptation of
the brothers Grim fairy tale Snow White
called Snow White and the evil queen the
film which is set to release in 2024
will be the first featur length
production of the company's kids
entertainment platform called bent key
which will star Brett Cooper host of the
platform show the comment section they
have the trailer here uh you can watch
it I I don't I don't want to play it or
maybe we should how was it did you watch
it it's really short I'll just I'm just
going to play it because I think it's
news
relevant Once Upon A
[Music]
Time In Time a prince would
come
is this bar Cooper singing yes
upon now that time is
[Music]
gone okay I'm really excited but I only
have one issue I don't think they should
have cast Brett Cooper yeah I because uh
I just feel like if you're a political
commentator and personality trying to
push you into scripted and fiction is
just kind of like you know like for Ian
it kind of makes sense because he's not
a political commentator personality he
is an actor first and it's kind of
obvious in the way he views politics no
offense but I think people understand
he's not this is not his main thing but
then when they watch him do like the
bits and the shorts in the cast Castle
stuff they're like wow he knows how to
act well well yeah it's like that's his
thing but I will say what's really funny
about this is you know Disney's putting
out their new Snow White and they're
doing this like Snow White and the Seven
Companions thing right where they got
rid of the dwarfs because Peter Dinklage
didn't want anyone any other dwarfs to
have and then other dwarf people were
like why are you ruining rules for us we
I think that's so ridiculous especially
when you look at the Wizard of Oz and
how all of those dwarves got to meet
each other and start families and fall
in love and stuff like the hell Peter
Dinklage yeah he's like but I will I
will say Brett Cooper fits the role
substantially better than Rachel Ziggler
or Ziggler whatever her name is she also
probably likes it better I mean Rachel
Ziggler hates the role hates the story
but like I'm I'm actually really
interested to watch the Disney version I
I I haven't had Disney plus since that
uh uh uh the the Concentration Camp
thing they supported so I'm just like
yeah I'm not going to watch
concentration you mean the Gina corano
thing no Disney plus thanked the uh
security forces in uh was it in shinjang
y yeah where where
concentration mul good yeah and I was
like um that's
creep we'll see ourselves out I'm like
Disney does a lot of things that I think
are cringe and woke and I always tell
people like yeah but I don't expect
everyone to just cancel all of their uh
we got a s b they cancel all their
entertainment right away we need to
create Alternatives but like when they
thank the security forces that are
enforcing like that we acknowledge as a
genocide like you know I'm just not
going to give you any money but uh but
anyway I'm really interested despite all
that to see how they handle the Seven
Companions like which one's going to be
like Dopey and Doc and you know what I
mean oh they're probably going to be
like woki and you know they them
and do you remember when Marvel tried
doing like the New Mutants I think it
was and they had Snowflake and safe
space were two of the characters they
made yes this is what they're going to
do with them they can't they can't
insult people by calling them Sneezy
that's that's that's ableist why didn't
they do uh Snow White and the polycule
oh
and she's like I too racy for them they
like racy have you seen the people in
these polycules they're not racy for
particular I'm just saying like that's
too far just send a message to Ashley St
Clair she's at the Babylon B and I think
that we should do this Ashley if you're
out there snow white will be play by
it's a morbidly obese woman and she's
got a bunch of guys all around her and
she's like I don't need a prince cuz
I've got all this and the guys are like
we're happy well and the guys are mostly
trans they're mostly trans and and would
the wicked Queen be hot as opposed to
the Snow White in
this like her sister likey weird I have
the legit question about about how daily
wire is doing Snow White are they going
to make it's Snow White and the evil
queen okay is the evil queen going to be
a communist and I don't mean like
literally like they make a movie and the
queen walks out and she's got like a
sickle you know hammer or whatever but
is it going to be an analogy for merit
and Independence and the evil queen is
jealous communism right I certainly hope
that the evil queen is vain and power
hungry yeah like she's supposed to she's
supposed to be I don't understand why we
would take here's what they should do
they should be like the evil queen
retains Power by telling all of the
suffering people that she's actually
helping them and that it's better this
way and then Snow White is like no no
lift yourselves up work hard and defeat
the evil queen I hope it's a story about
uh individualism and is not involved in
the political realm at all yeah I hope
it's about van and struggles of aging
and youth I don't know that it has to be
tied to political ideology and the value
of of love over seeking to dominate your
opposition there's a part in the
original Disney Snow White that haunts
me to this day it's when Snow White's
baking her pie and then she looks up and
it just has the wicked Queen in the
window and has the old lady and it just
it's nightmare fuel to this this crazy
look at this daily wi says bent key will
be available at launch with 150 episodes
of 18 shows including b key Originals
new episodes are due to arrive every
Saturday morning so oh Saturday morning
cartoons so we we're talking about what
we're trying to do and it's
substantially smaller than what the
daily wire is doing but uh we're
launching the coffee shop Cas Brew up in
everyone probably knows where it is now
in barsburg and we're going to do the
anti Time Square but the main reason we
want to do it is not that we think we're
going to get super wealthy off having a
coffee shop it's that Saturday mornings
are when we invite families to come in
for a caded breakfast with their kids
and you know what we'll do we'll uh
we'll play The Daily wires cartoons cuz
we know they're new and they're going to
be good for families and kids and of
course I'll talk to the Daily wire first
I just rip their content and play it for
everybody but I'm sure they they'll be
cool you should probably just rip their
content and play it for everybody
there's literally no reason to do that
I'm sure if I asked Jeremy I was like
hey we want to play Saturday morning
your Saturday morning cartoons for
families at our coffee shop he'd be like
please like tell them to tell their
friends I really like that they did this
for kids and I really wish them the best
with it I hope that they have a lot of
success uh there's we been starved for
Content like that for our children so I
really really appreciate it so thank you
guys I mean look Brett Cooper is
probably really good in this role she
fits the role better than Rachel zagler
and she's got an amazing singing voice
I'm just kind of like you've already
she's a political commentator you know
she transitioning back to acting I think
that was her origin right yeah she comes
she's coming from that to be a political
commentator I think for me more than
anything I am kind of tired of the
remakes of you know Disney Classics and
all these things I'd be really curious
to see their original content they're
saying there's all these shows or if
they were to take some other folk tale
that has there's so many like there's
all over the place yeah there was like a
a whole bunch of stories from the um
abanaki and alanan tribes in New England
yeah and they were recorded there was
this like what in the 18 whatevers you
know this uh Anthropologist went around
and recorded all of the stories from the
Aging Native Americans who were
basically on their way out they were
like you know old people dying the
stories weren't going to uh stories
weren't going to last forever and he
wrote them all down and then uh you know
published a book of all of these
fascinating stories like there was this
one about this woman who um she lives
with her parents and she falls in love
with this guy and she uh her parents are
like no no no he's a terrible guy and
then she runs away from home to be with
this guy and uh goes to live with him
and eventually her parents go to find
her and she's like all alone by this
Lake because it turns out that she
married a sea serpent fascinating
fascinating there's all these
straing the there's the story of the
chenu which is this like ice heart
person MH these are all fascinating
stories and of course this
Anthropologist was like a white guy from
Harvard I'm pretty sure and um his book
has been widely discredited because he
was white and recording these stories
God forbid right and they're fascinating
stories but I would love to see also
some of the other Grim fairy tales yeah
you know I think that there's more
content than we give credit to and the
fact that I get why it's like oh we had
this Rachel eagler thing so now we
should make our own some white but I'd
actually like to see daily wire just
Embrace more expansive American culture
and the folktales that come with both
European and American culture that we
don't already have because it's when
they do their own original stuff that's
when I think they're at their strongest
I don't really need to see another
version of Snow White and it would be
great to have more American Myth and
Legend in our daily you know content and
storytelling I would love that
absolutely one of my favorite uh I guess
underrated fairy tales is called
Princess furball oh that's cute yes it's
it's adorable and it's just about this
this princess whose family had passed
and then she was supposed to be sent
away to go marry some some like Troll
and uh she was like okay but you need to
do this favor for me I'm going to need
three dresses one as bright as the sun
one as bright as the moon and one as
dark as the night sky and she was able
to um and then she wanted a fur coat
made of the fur of a thousand different
animals and she she made all these
requests because she's like they're
never going to be able to to do this and
they they did it and the the king F coat
sounds really mean yes I know right p is
livid I would I would yeah so but anyway
get an one coat and then she shoves
these dresses which are these big
elaborate dresses into these Walnut
shells and uh puts them in her pocket
and then they find her so this other
Kingdom finds her cuz she runs away she
doesn't marry the troll she runs away
with with her coat and her Walnut her
Walnut suitcases right and they find her
so this other king finds her hiding in
like a a tree and they think she's an
animal because she covered in this coat
of a thousand first and so they're like
oh and they realize she's a human
they're like oh well you can be a slave
in our kitchen she's like Okay cool so
she goes she be a slave in the kitchen
and then she decides she wants to sneak
away to the ball you know and that's I
don't want to spoil the end of Princess
furball for everybody but you know it it
gets it gets better than that so I would
I would do a princess fball that's
that's the thing there are so many cool
stories both you know written and you
know folklore that has passed down from
different cultures I'd love to just move
away from just recycling the same ones
that Disney already made I agree it's
it's cooler to see original stuff even
if we're remakes of Disney's
interpretations of the stories instead
of retellings of the original fables
there are remakes of redheads in Disney
there are just no redheads they get rid
of them well you're
not minity daily wies got a red on beny
maybe that's not an original red
head uh no there's no way it's too
uniform this is their launch I
suppose there you go I don't know I just
fun maybe that maybe that's part of the
whole message like we're not going to
delete the redheads well you guys are a
genetic Global minority you I don't
understand why no one advocates for you
because because we're not we're not
wimps we don't we don't care that people
you know erase us we're like whatever
you should you should be louder about it
I don't this cause gets enough
attention yeah the one thing I disagree
with is the Muppet oh I don't know if
you can legally call it a muppet cuz
it's like a protected term or whatever
but I've just never been a fan of like
the weird puppet things I don't like the
kids puppet shows Sesame Street fine I
guess whatever that one a the cartoons I
think are good I never knew a cookie
fragle Rock did you not like Fraggle
Rock I did not no you didn't like frag
Rock I despise Muppets you despise I
really really like the Muppets
I do like the muet I did like Fraggle
Rock Miss Piggy is just is just exists
to make fun of Liz Cheney but I'm not I
am not insulting Li cheny I am saying
that people cre but I mean like that's
the value of Miss Piggy to mock someone
like this Janie it's really did you like
Kermit when he was in those car
commercials that's what I I didn't watch
them Muppet growing up but I do remember
those car commercials where it was
always it was like for a hybrid car and
so they brought out watch show on TV
it was on TV oh Kermit being green I get
it yeah hybrid Y and I think it was on
during the American Idol uh commercial
breaks I could be wrong but the Muppet
Show was on TV and it was I believe it
was I believe it was on Sunday nights
yeah and I watched it and the Muppet
Show was really cool because it was uh
it was like a it was like behind the
scenes it was like a live act it was
like their they were putting on a show
and there was scooter was the stage
manager I loved that that's fun see I
think there are there is space for
original content that's that's an
example of original content that you
can't just be like and so we're going to
make our own version of The Muppet Show
that's essentially the same thing like
pick something new pick something fresh
because Muppet babies and they they get
all the spin-offs I appreciate that star
war when when you load the website this
is what it looks
like I like chinchilla because it also
like when when it loads it then jumps to
a thing like sign up now but this is
what it shows before showing the sign up
now oh is she reading a book about
herself
is that what she's doing probably I
don't know she is is that her name
narcissism rampant wait a minute what
values are they promoting maybe she's
playing the evil queen and that's the
vanity and the power hungry she redhead
too though I know unfortunately but I
guess I guess one of my questions too is
like so a lot of the cartoons for kids
are they don't really teach lessons it's
just kind of kids entertainment so it's
silly like Fairly Odd Parents yeah so
it's like not in it's not inappropriate
for the kids but it's also not educ I'm
wondering if are they going for more
Educational Learning life lessons you
know I think that I I don't think that
all entertainment needs that stuff and I
don't think that it should be
inorganically I do like there are the
undertones like um Jack bobic wrote that
book about the island of ice cream and
it I I have that book but it's it's got
all these undertones about why
meritocracy is good why communism is bad
and and but it doesn't read that way to
a child but to great I like his book too
is wonderful but I I like to see stories
organically have a morality to them as
opposed to have it be the morality is
the reason you're making the story like
you want it to be part of the narrative
intentionally yeah more Blended more
Blended and not about like I have an
ideological perspective and now I'm
going to make a cartoon listening right
I was listening to this whole thing
about um I was doing so you know Israel
war whatever I don't know very much
about Israel I don't know very much
about any of it so I started doing like
some research research and digging into
it and Hamas had this um children's show
where it was about it was basically
teaching children that the best thing
they can do in life is be jihadis oh my
goodness but that makes sense why
wouldn't they make that as well they did
make that and so the first main
character died as a Jihadi and they had
like can you know they him more
characters after that of children giving
their lives to jihadis that's crazy and
that was that was on TV in Gaza wow I
mean it's it's not like so in you
Christian fath there there's Martyrs you
know but but we don't we don't preach
that like it is good to be a martyr
here's a show about Martyrs and you're
going to be a martyr and these children
are martyring so it's it's just weird
the way that it's presented in this way
well it was a shift too like from the
research I've done anyway you know it
was a shift in the uh it became like a
far it was a
extremist
Islamic um group right so it wasn't like
your your just everyday Muslims it
became this extremist idea that
infiltrated incrementally and then
eventually what they started to do was
like when Hamas was founded in like ' 88
and they started attacks in ' 89 and it
kept going but then they started
providing and then they won the election
you know against like what fat I think
it was but they um they started
providing all these Social Services cuz
I was like why did the people of Gaza
elect Hamas to lead them in 2006 after
Israel Israel withdrew why did they do
that and so I was trying to figure that
out too and it was because Hamas was
providing all of these Social Services
they were providing schools and
hospitals and all of these things and so
they offered this big promise but the
promise comes with this horrific price I
have a friend who lived under the
Taliban and uh this is this is uh
probably six seven eight years ago now
but he would write me and he' tell me
all the good things that the Taliban did
for them and a lot of Social Services ma
did things too other than how supporters
right you offer them what they need
right and I mean if you know the lessons
of CH Gua tell us anything it's that
like if you're going to do this kind of
Revolution and take control you need the
support of the people to do it exactly
definitely and the people think they
depend on you which you kind of look at
the social programs in America and it
kind of answers all the question and
then you start to wonder too like what
are you know what we've given up in
return for those social programs is
pretty extreme thankfully not as extreme
I think the more but ours were faced in
over time so people became more
incremental me and um me and Jack bobic
were talking about this the
incrementalism of evil yep and like how
creep a they let you become comfortable
the more migrants that we have here the
more social programs we're going to need
the more Reliant people come so it's
it's definitely a trickle it's and we
had yeah we had a writer at at human
events who did a dive and comparing all
of the different things um of what Jihad
is and like comparing it to the Quran
and like digging into different
translations and she's kind of this
crazy genius actually um but uh the
first the first stage of jihad is when
you're Islamic and you're a minority in
the culture and you just normalize Your
Existence you like say that you're just
really nice and all of this stuff and
then it's just this incremental approach
um it's it's really terrifying to look
at some of these ideologies of like
total hatred of the other and how it
morphs and takes over yeah some of the
Hadith are just literally written about
that almost exactly just about being
against somebody else and about like how
you're to struggle against this person
because that's what it means the word
means struggle so that's a better way to
look at it but you're you're right all
that stuff yeah it's really crazy let's
go to super chats all right everybody if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel head over over to
timcast.net the projects were engaged
and succeed you can also buy Casper
coffee but being a member at Tim
cast.com is the most direct way to allow
us to continue doing the work we do all
right I'm not your buddy guy is back he
is once again the first Super Chat
saying if you wanted to destroy the us
yet maintain some plausible deniability
would you do anything different from
what Biden has done
agreed yeah it's it's it's like it's
just abject failure yeah it's
demoralization destabilization crisis
and normalization yep Clint Tores says
howdy people Tim forgive my misspeak
about your upcoming discussion about
religion but my misstatement still
stands I'm by no means Catholic but as I
trust you for your honest news I trust
father Mike schmidtz on theology yeah
the plan is to get fresh from fresh and
fit Ian and Sheamus cogin and we're
going to do a culture War episode
discussing religion and spirituality be
cool oh interesting which will be wild I
think she is really interesting thinker
Sheamus is going to be like pulling his
hair the whole time being like guys guys
guys but think a lot of people ask shame
I mean I I know personally I ask him
tons of questions about you know how he
got to where he is he's probably
prepared to uh to argue the point um but
it'd be curious to hear the other
perspective and what questions they
would raise I would I could talk about
that all day like religion and faith and
I'm gonna have Ian on my show on Sunday
I think to talk about spirituality oh on
Spaces nice yes Stephen says says pray
for my brothers and sisters in the meu
that is deployed may God keep them safe
here here God bless absolutely man
absolutely all right what do we have
let's grab some more Super chats what is
this someone mentioning jet fuel and
steel beams uh one person nonpartisan
Kitty says bringeth thy bcus on today's
show well I mean we would but Ian's not
here and usually he's the one who'll run
down and go grab him but uh bcus it's
tough I saw him the other day and he was
just sitting by his water we have the
Little Flower automatically that sprays
the water out and I went up in the
morning was just sitting there looking
kind of lethargic and when I came down
he's in the exact same spot which is not
a good sign yeah however later that
night he followed me downstairs as I was
leaving into the green room and then
apparently after I left he started
zipping around running so oh that's
great or whenever you like if I go to
fill a water bottle he'll come running
out of no like I don't even know where
he is he'll suddenly appear because he
really likes the faucet water he does so
sometimes I think he's not doing so well
and other times I think he's just not
correctly motivated yeah right well the
Zoomies are good he's he's been alive
like a year longer than he was supposed
to like a year ago he was stumbling
falling over and and just crapping where
where he stood and we thought that was
it and then we put him on like a drug
cocktail which is like he's got a heart
defect he's got bad kidneys so I miss
having cats yeah let me know like like
send me some pictures I can paint him
for you I'd like to do that oh yeah all
right all right what do we have uh let's
see Alex Hilbert says I saw y'all were
eating MREs last week you better get
used to picking the right one private
pool if World War III Goes Down based on
the numbers in my unit there will be a
large
draft private pool yep uh yeah and I'm
gonna I'm I'm you know what am I looking
at five more months until I'm
38 so if this war breaks out oh 38y olds
you're you're you're getting picked up
no question I mean we're not first in
line you know draft I mean Ukraine's
doing women 18 to 60 so you right right
right but to be fair I am rich and rich
people don't get drafted so all I got to
do is make the right contribution to a
senator and I'm good safe but an all
seriousness that's basically how it's
always operated if you were Rich you got
out of the draft well connected that's
why so many presidents would well what
they would do back in the day what they
would do is if like a wealthy family had
their son drafted they would pay for
someone to take his place yes wow yeah
crazy y it's cool you can actually see
what draft numbers were pulled during
the draft the last one and I would have
been drafted for a guy my birthday was
pulled yep oh my dad's number was how
they did it they did by birthday they
did it by birthday birthday yeah my
dad's number was called up but he didn't
have to go why because he's deathly
afraid of bees really what a fascinating
way to get out of this well so what was
interesting is his number came up and he
was like okay guess I'm doing this and
my mom was like nope and she like went
around and got like a doctor's letter
and all this stuff and he didn't end up
going that's great yeah I think
eventually he told me once and I don't
know if he still feels this way cuz now
he's like in his 70s and he's recovering
from cancer and he's like very mellowed
out and sort of fast he's like really
brilliant my dad he's like really he's
in a reflective phase of Life reflective
phase of life and he's got like a ton of
kids and we're all weird but whatever
but he told me once that he had some
regrets about not having gone when his
you know peers had gone y of course all
right what do we have here I'm grateful
I would not be alive RW b y Nora saying
Appalachian nights is the best cup of
coffee I've ever had please think about
a app night an app night dark chocolate
mocha blend thank you all much love a
mocha blend would be well the coffee
originally is like we're opening a
coffee shop so we wanted to the coffee
that was the fastest and easiest thing
to do the coffee's been wildly
successful so uh in terms mean to buy
some it it honestly it is my favoritee
you haven't already I thought you liked
us Libby I'm a member you're fired but
uh the coffee shop is just taking
forever because of uh construction and
permitting reasons which sucks and now
Winter's coming so we'll see you know
it's like the coffee shop supposed to be
open like six months ago then seven
months or five months ago then four and
three and it was supposed to be open in
two weeks and now it's going to be
another year who knows but we are
planning on a bunch of other stuff so we
do have the coffee which is cool right
and that's why I was like we're we're
we're we're you know it's it's a multi
multi uh uh multipronged approach we we
produced the coffee we're selling that
we have the website now we're waiting
for the building to get set up once the
building get we're also working on the
franchise Corporation documents and and
proper paperwork so that we can start
popping these things up all over the
place and having people sign up to to
run them I was excited that we had the K
cups ready when we were uh stuffing gift
bags in Miami the K cups were there seen
them yeah yeah neglectful sausage says
just remember DS9 season 5 episode 11
The Darkness and Light Kira said you
were all valid targets you didn't belong
here about trying to un alive a butler
cardi and to DS9 writers she was the
good guy yeah that's true she was always
the good guy even though she was a she
had been basically a terrorist
yeah that's right that show is good that
show is so good yeah it's my favorite
Star Trek these days I think I have
watched D9 all the way through like like
Joseph metler says Trump was reported to
have told Putin and she at the G20 that
if they invaded anyone he would nuke
them as in them personally not their
countries I'm sorry there's just no one
like him where is he when we need him
most oh wait we didn't elect him to kill
them to their FA in Iowa he's an Iowa
saying that my personal right I loved
his thing about like my personality is
why we didn't have wars what is that
quote I'm GNA find the quote it's not
wrong though I had it's correct what's
great about it and he is also s my
personality kept us out of War that's
what he said I one of my one of I don't
talk about my sisters that much one of
my sisters was a redhead and when she
was two she had a pentis but it went
under diagnosed for like a week and she
was in ex it was crazy I told you story
before and when they finally brought her
to the right hospital after like three
or four trips and the doctor was finally
like oh yeah this is appendicitis that's
exactly what's going on it looked like
shrapnel floating around her abdomen oh
God she went into surgery and the
surgeon came out and was like she is
alive because of the force of her
personality and I think this is real
with some people and he attributed to
the red hair he said she was like really
obstinate she was the most fero she was
always a ferocious toddler but she was
like even when she was in excruciating
pain could not be moved it was awful no
one faar what was going on it was just
like it was her way and nothing else to
the whole thing and I swear that's what
kept her alive and I think that's why
Donald Trump saying the force of my
personality kept out of war is actually
an extremely valid point some people are
just meant to be in certain situations
their personalities can handle
it Raymond g Stanley Jr says question
for y'all how do you guys think a draft
would go will families move out of the
country join up or tell the government
to go suck an egg depends on the
circumstances by which we enter the war
if right now Joe Biden just says we have
War have a nice day yeah then yeah draft
would never fly if something happens to
the president then sure many of the Maga
types are going to be like no way I'm
not getting involved but a lot of more
liberal and moderate and NPC like
families would have no problem
whatsoever in that instance in fact
you'll probably get a lot of
conservatives too who are going to have
attitude of like I may not like Joe
Biden he may have been a bad guy but
you've you've you know this is our
family right it's kind of like when you
like a brother and sister who fight all
the time and hate each other but then
outside someone calls the girl ugly and
the go like don't talk about my sister
cuz it's like you know I'm allowed to
argue with my family not you yeah or
insult my family anyone with a lot of
siblings I think can really relate to
that let's grab some more Super chats
blanket Senpai says hey Tim please try
cyberpunk 2077 as it deals with topics
related to the show Waring ideological
factions Corporation Wars technology and
AI I tried playing it I couldn't do it I
don't know did you play it uh no my
little brother did I think but not
really for me I'm not much of a gamer in
case anyone hasn't noticed Pino Shay's
helicopter tour says Marines age cap on
entrance is 28 all other branches of
military is 35 however you can get a
waiver in World War II up to 64 yearolds
were drafted for war that's true yeah
yikes yep I think I I like the idea that
if you vote you we hold the vote should
we go to war if you vote Yes we draft
you yeah you personally are going
Lindsey Graham oh yeah lindsy Graham's
on the front line yeah I don't
understand I mean he's in office until
2027 and yet he's like get ready for all
the kids I'm going to send to war mhm
it's too much all right where are we
at Sensei tank 94 says Tim YouTube is
aggressively hiding the live show today
I love the slow Rumble transition for
the long game keep it up brother
Independent Media will save us all keep
at it Friday had a really really hard
time finding the link to the show cuz I
wasn't on so I was trying to find it I
had to go I looked it up on your channel
I like everything no no Friday uh when
dases was on and I ended up only being
able to find the link because Ian had
tweeted it out I could not find it on
YouTube even the preview thing wasn't
showing up it crazy what do you mean the
preview thing is wasn't people will go
they'll go to the YouTube channel itself
and it's not there yeah that's what
happened to me on Friday and I was
thinking with like everything we thought
might happen or because of culture War
like I don't know right to live page and
it's literally just not going to be
there won't show up at all y yeah it was
crazy yep Rumble and X are the Future
YouTube is dying and also sort of offing
itself it seems like why did you Hive
such a high profile live show well it's
because we have the wrong political
opinions yeah it's probably ESG Dei
related I I wonder though I really do
look there's a lot of we were skating
today in the garage and uh I'm like for
the first time in a year whatever turned
the TV on cuz we have a TV in the park
and I was playing YouTube music videos
we got a bunch of commercials pro pro
Israel commercials very graphic
commercials crazy I can't believe they
were playing some of these these
commercials but you know I wonder if you
made a YouTube show that was like
explicitly pro Israel Pro uh Pro
intervention would it be prominently
displayed on the front page for
everybody I kind of think it would I
think you'd get hundreds of thousands of
Liv like if we came out right away on
this show and started saying things like
we must intervene I'm willing to bet
YouTube would promote us front page i'
get a phone call from Susan she'd be
like your show's doing so oh well like
you know we're we're doing a new pilot
program for marketing we'd love to
promote you that's interesting I wonder
if that would happen probably they they
tolerate us because we're like moderate
hey civilians shouldn't die we're not
for intervention but Hamas are
terrorists and what they did was evil
and wrong and so they're like okay well
it's not all bad you know if we came out
like I I I'd be curious to see what
would happen to the likes of you know
Hassan or maybe the other leftists who
are like cheering on
terrorists interesting to see but
apparently I've been hearing that um
it's an interesting dynamic because uh
uh Hassan does that podcast with Ethan
Klein oh yeah and Ethan Klein's Jewish
and I'm pretty sure his wife is from
Israel yeah was like she was in the IDF
I think right she was yeah and so it
must be like really weird now to like
they released any episodes yeah yeah
yeah I need a body I need a body
language expert to start reacting to
their show and be like OB tension in the
room it's it's a really weird thing to
see that these people uh many on the
left have have no moral position other
than they hate the United States and
they hate the right M so that's why they
say like queers for Palestine or
whatever it's completely contradictory
it makes no sense completely illegal in
Gaza it's a 10year prison sentence
that's that's the that's the actual hard
uh law 10 years in prison but they say
these things and it's just like
eventually the Dam breaks and a question
of ideology emerges where they realize
they were never aligned with each other
they actually just agreed on who they
hated yeah right that's not well that
was interesting too that was like um
part of my research is uh so Israel
expelled a bunch of this was I forget
when maybe it was in the 80s Israel
expelled a bunch of um Hamas guys maybe
it was after I don't know they expelled
a bunch of Hamas guys to Lebanon and
then Hezbollah and Hamas teamed up even
though one is Sunni and one is Shia they
were like that's okay we all hate the
Jews yeah right that's what I've been
saying I've been worried about is if
that if that really and it is clearly
happening now as it happens more and and
then Iran like helped train
bricks negotiating a truce between the
shiats and the sunn yeah I don't like
any
of and then they'll just all come for us
highly sus this is interesting uh Colt
ziani someone's GNA have to break this
down for me he says thoughts on the
Army's Lake City Ammunition plant
operated by Winchester is seizing sales
to civilians civy sales account for 30%
but the FED needs the ammo fortune
tellers follow the money are you saying
that the Army is basically
go like buying out all the ammo with
like a first right to purchase what it
looks like over civilians from what
they're saying that's what it looks like
yeah remember when everyone was
concerned about the IRS buying a bunch
of bullets
yeah why are they buying hollow points
it's starting to get weird yeah well
it's because they have special agents
who are armed yeah true but this is all
like right in time for Halloween it's
not just the spookiest weird scary world
October October is always messed up do
you remember in 2016 where there were
all the killer clowns I do remember that
what a time right that was weird went
away it's and we just all pretend that
that never happened what if they didn't
go away they're just looking around and
we got distracted yeah that's true they
they got bored they're like all right
they're not paying attention
anymore I don't like country tunic says
if a draft is issued neither me nor my
friends or family are going to serve an
illegitimate government and go die for
the
elites yeah you'll get to ja the thing
is I think we all agree on this but the
draft I think they ultimately want a
draft but they know they can't do it
until they have some sort of rallying
moment for uh patriotic and nationalist
Sport and I just don't think Joe Biden's
the guide to make that happen maybe
that's why they're sending him to Israel
something happens to Joe Biden and then
Trump gets elected and then it's Donald
Trump calling for it right yeah cuz I
think people would serve if Trump asked
them too yes but I don't think that if
Biden died people are going to go sign
up to to go avenge Biden's death which
is problem for the Deep state right now
that Trump is the only one who could get
a draft to work yeah I agree with you
guys
man hybd says Biden going to Israel is a
complete setup everyone can see this as
a telegraphed Pearl Harbor Lucitania
moment and with that we should hold all
who is allowed it accountable in the end
what we the people do I I got to be
honest I really I think 99.9% Biden goes
to Israel it's boring and he comes back
and then starts preaching about why we
need we need to defend them I'm just
saying that there's a concern that it's
like probably a really bad idea to on
the president to enactive conflict Zone
like this doesn't seem it doesn't follow
a certain pattern it should follows it
follows a pattern it shouldn't follow
which is why it's alarming to us yeah
mhm true our borders too un David
Toronto says if we let a country kill
our president then we have no country
yes that's my point even if it's a bad
one even if it's a bad president exactly
that's exactly my I agree with you there
fella totally agree
man all right where we
at Brand Dizzle says can you think of a
better way to get Nome to be the Dem
candidate than sending Biden to an
active war zone no not it doesn't make
sense that they are sing him unless they
want something to happen to him what do
what do they think like what is the
upside is the thing I can't figure out
the upside there is the approval rating
of Biden is in the trash but it's not
going to get well if something God
forbid happened to him or if he went
over there and showed a show of strength
for America that could up his numbers
what is a Joe Biden show of strength not
falling down the stairs or there saying
something so low saying something
scripted and direct he can't even do
that State of the Union the way he does
that that would be my only way for
people to or just his the just going
there you think they Jack him up on
drugs so he could do that he had IV
marks on his hand what what if it's not
that they target Biden but like a
preschool and then Biden runs into the
burning building and like comes out
carrying kids and he's like come on man
I did the best I could and then he just
like collapses from smoke inhalation and
they're like he can't run though the
only problem maybe they gave him a bike
that had the training wheels on weing
his body double and that one
enough enough Pharmaceuticals and you
could you could do
anything yeah true I don't know I just
like I said we were all upset about
Ukraine we spent billions of dollars on
it he didn't go for a year not even that
far into well you know what's interest
like we spent 113 billion on Ukraine
since February 2022 M and I think we
give Israel per a deal from 2016 it was
like 38 billion over 10 years and it's
like Israel's done a lot better with
that money than Ukraine has done with
theirs well we're just obviously
laundering money through Ukraine very
bad let's read some more we got the Dude
abides he says hey Tim hear me out when
you guys do the anti Time Square you
should have a New Year's ball drop in
the center as well but instead of a
giant glowing ball it should be a giant
glowing rooster let the jokes begin
it's actually a really good idea be fine
like I thought it'd be really cool it's
like you don't have a ball drop or a
rooster drop you have a rooster that
crows right at the strike of midnight
that' be fun and it's like the it's like
wake up to a new dawn you know yeah
that's cool beautiful yeah and I think
everybody out here cuz everyone everyone
out here literally everyone owns
chickens they would all love it yeah if
un people people don't realize when you
live out in West Virginia like you go
hang out we don't watch the game we talk
chickens like you go to your buddy's
house and you're like oh chickens oh
well yeah rooster it's like oh I got a
rooster too you're really close friend
you start talking about are you going to
get goats cuz I'm thinking about getting
goats I really wanted to sh it's
actually like half true no I'm not
kidding we were talking we me and Hannah
CLA were actually talking about this the
other day cuz I was saying that I wanted
to make my own cheese yeah and what the
best idea is to have some sort of goat
or you probably don't have an affan for
a cow but like a sheep you get a mini
cow oh sheep you get there mini cows
yeah they produce like a gallon of milk
per day instead of 12 that's all you
need that's manageable for your
household that is manageable I would I
would be making so many cakes if I had
that the uh I'm always just working from
liby's house me pizzas I would make you
pizzas and cakes and cookies the other
night best of all time he was like Mom
do we have any dessert and I was like no
but I could make some cookies and he was
like okay and we made cookies you leave
New York and suddenly you're like the
best 1950s no well no I was doing that
stuff anyway oh sure but it's better now
with your own cow your own eggs soon I'm
getting a new couch actually I'm very
excited the the kids Charlie uh my son
and his friend they broke my
couch uh they were jumping around it was
already sort of broken and held together
with wood glue so this was it was a long
time coming yeah um Joshua 029 Article 1
Section 8 C1 shall make him out of let
uh shall make shall make him out letters
of Mark under the Great Seal and by
virtue of these he may attack and seize
the property of the aggressor Nation
without Hazard of being condemned as a
robber or pirate so priv basic private
Corsair Pirates way more fun to say but
yes are we going have kids in school
they're like when I grow up I want to be
a pirate mhm I mean that's pretty cool
if that's that's they could actually
live their dreams I feel like it's more
realistic than becoming an astronaut as
long as as long as they don't say mom I
want to have a peg leg and no eye and
then the mom's like you know what this
is how you identify so yeah we're going
to take you to the doctors and take your
eye and your leg cuz you're a pirate
that's who you I mean tattoos uh have
increased over the last decade people
death too so maybe we are just ready for
pirate culture to come back hey I mean
there's a bunch of young men my age are
looking for work so yeah sounds like
it's a good idea for him Duke Karm says
Tim Brett Cooper was a legitimate
actress who's been on TV and in movies
long before joining the daily wire true
I am I am I am aware I know I just feel
like for the daily wire to have her you
know multi multi class I think when you
make a choice to change your career you
know sometimes you have to stick with it
like well no I mean like it's just like
the daily wire doing it just feels like
I don't know man it just feels like
you're doing too much yeah well like if
she's trying to build her brand as a
political commentator it's not that she
couldn't do it she couldn't do both
things but it sometimes makes sense to
stay in one lane if that's the thing
that you're building up I mean I don't
know she wants to be an actress like
this this is why I'm never in the cast
Castle stuff for the most part I just it
I I don't know like the music stuff is
fine because it's always kind of like a
a side thing but starring in movies like
cameos I think are fine you know look
I'll just keep it vague there have been
people who approached us and be like
would you like to be in a film or I'm no
never going to happen TV show movie
uh-uh nope I'm not going to do it yeah I
think as long as there's no like overt
political messaging in this then it'll
be good but if they try and put too much
into it it's just going to be like H the
cringe factor is just way too high it
just it's just like right there but I
don't know hopefully they hopefully they
will all right let's just grab we'll
grab a couple more here thinker for Life
says all super chats over $50 should get
free coffee it would just be impossible
to actually Implement that system like
if you send in a Super Chat that big
like we can't track your address and
things like that and and you got sales
accent oh heavens Heavens but we are
working on protein powder stuff which is
going to be fun and uh Alex Stein's
coffee is almost done we've got the bags
uh uh the Design's ready what's it
called Alex Stein's Prime Time grind two
times caffeine nice awesome I'm excited
about it I like that he's super excited
we're super excited oh I'm excited
that's G to be good and then we're we're
we're interested in doing an Ian coffee
as well oh cool what would Ian's coffee
be I don't know we got talk to Yan about
it it would be like caffeine-free like
mellow
Brew I was thinking maybe
yeah maybe it's like yeah maybe it would
be like so I think we have like a light
and dark single Source it would be like
single Source yeah we got we're doing
focus with Mr bcus which will be our es
espresso be fun I like that focus with
Mr
Bokus and uh let's just grab one more
one more Super Chat what do we have here
I would just want to do like a nice
daring tea hunter killer says daily wire
should make a movie about Robert Smalls
the former slave who commandeered a
Confederate ship and used it to free
slaves that would the left to
self-destruct into nonsense I agree
interes great story yeah all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and share the
show with your friends if you like it
head over to
timcast.net official and uh go over to
timcast And subscribe there to become a
member and help support our work yeah uh
I'm Han cler rmla I'm a writer for
timcast.net and on Instagram it's the
best you can see work from me from Chris
burtman from Adrian Norman we have a
cool staff I like them a lot if you want
to follow me personally I'm on Instagram
at han. and I'm on Twitter at HC brimo
thank you so much and I'm so glad Libby
could be here tonight hey thanks Santa
Clair uh I'm Libby Emmons you can find
me on Twitter uh or whatever you guys
call it now whatever we don't get name
here on the internet I don't care um
Libby emens you can find me there I'm on
Instagram uh libby. emens and of course
what you should really do is come check
out the post
millennial.age
subscribe and to all my South African
friends bab Booka let's win against the
English once more and take back the web
Ellis it's ours uh make sure you watch
the game anyways cheers we'll see you
all over at timcast.net